une production du studio sf bio sans fil
dans le podcast où on parle de ce qu'on
veut que nos invités date du site je
suis h 30 avec moi d'une plante
si vous voulez nous entendre parler
davantage pour vous abonner à notre
petrillo nous est ce que hp chaque
podcast on discute
nicole deux mois on fait encore moins de
filtres wascon diam un petit peu sur la
conversation qu'on met d'abord fait un
genre de fouilles star a cappella sur
des sujets qu'on a abordé beaucoup de
beatbox madame la déception du podcast
puis date sinon cette semaine cette
semaine grand plaisir de recevoir une
colonie vernois notre honneur québécois
avec les valeurs à la bonne place
engagé qu'encourageante renard hyoki qui
s'intéressent à la politique s'intéresse
en fait à tous les sujets on est
tellement dans plein de directions
différentes qui est une histoire
vraiment différent je le connaissais
rien dans votre connaissez rien par
l'entrepreneuriat avant de se lancer
dans cette aventure le ça a été un long
travail difficile pour maintenant
qui vivent le supplice qui connaissent
ce travail continue c'était vraiment les
est un geek et une facilité en plus avec
la communication à c'était vraiment
juste un vrai régal de s'entretenir avec
lui y est ce juste avant d'aller écouter
la conversation va les remercier nos
sponsors
le podcast c'est semaine et présenté par
la compagnie chante qui est une
compagnie innovante qui fait depuis
maintenant plus de quinze ans des
produits de soins naturels à base
d'huile de chambre pourquoi l'huile de
chanvre parce que ça permet à toutes les
autres composants des produits de mieux
fonctionner en fête et ont plus de 21
produits naturels la dernière fois je
vous avais parlé de la crème jugulaire
que j'ai adoré que m'a permis de réparer
ma blessure à la cuisse
maintenant d'hommes on parle d'un autre
oeil aujourd'hui on parle de crime pour
les moyens c'est pourtant ce crime il
aimait à bord des petites mains douces
et soyeuses alors chambre le produit
pour vous le l'huile de chanvre a fait
voter remettre au beurre de karité de de
mieux pénétrer les mêmes leur en faire
plus et fait qu' on n'a pas de résidus
gros sur les mains donc après sony peut
dire ce que l'on veut toucher aux eaux
chaudes et les huiles essentielles est
peut-être grèce puis à essentielle de
menthe d'hermach et de gingembre qui
permette d'apc d'apaiser pardon la peau
sèche et gercées des mains des fois le
bel
il vient de passer métier aussi des fois
on se lave les mains beaucoup l'avaient
avec le colonel hima gers et mac et
crème des crèmes pour les mains
ça fait du bien en un code promo c'est
sans filtre 25 pour 25 % de rabais sur
tous les produits sur le site change.gov
rssi la gagne chante le podcast cette
semaine et présenté par nos amis et
police lit dans mon parlait justement
petit peu plus tôt aujourd'hui de
comment ça pourrait être difficile
dormir avec quelqu'un
waouh commence t top pour le sommeil les
matelas pour les slips permettent
d'isoler le mouvement fait que si vous
voulez dormir avec quelqu'un ou même
avec un animal de compagnie
sachez que les mouvements de l'autre
personne de l'animal vont pas vous
déranger dans votre nuit de sommeil fait
que ça vous occupe la personne a vu se
lever pour aller à toilettes mais son
mouvement va être complètement isolé il
ya une petite vidéo d'hommes qui nous
qui nous démontre que tu m'expliquer la
vidéo pour les gens qui l'ont pas vu
voilà une vidéo plus voir un test pour
leslie plée puis les gorilles et jusque
dans son lit puis un verre de vin à côté
comme ci ou une autre personne dormirais
plus beau depuis ce rôle la barre devant
bouge pas du tout ça veut dire que vous
mouvement affecte pas du tout la
personne qui est à côté où l'animal ou
locaux qui bouge les robots qui est à
côté d'un si vous dormez avec un fort
beau ça fait vraiment ou si vous voulez
dormir avec votre barre de 20 aussi le
tir bas débit nous lever vous restez
l'oeil vous attend dans la même attaque
de les réveiller d'aller continuer à
voir des films tout à fait que suivre
les vous procurer un matelas pour leslie
de qualité extraordinaire
vous pouvez le faire en faisant le code
promo qui est le pôle isf 25 pour 25 %
de rabais le cas des valets du 11 au 24
mai donc dirigez-vous là dessus au plus
vite dans l'année dormez bien dormez
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sebbar si ça roule ça l'une cas là on
vient les gars ça merci pour
l'invitation ce succulent café d'air bag
ou tu sais pas si tu m'as n'aurait pas
autant que faisait une blague de piquer
mais mon épouse je prends juste du lait
d'avoine donc juste combat tentation ça
c'est une grosse nouveau lution quand
même les laits végétaux le sémaphore en
plus grande croissance des épiceries le
sud est nul il ya beaucoup de choses qui
se passent dans la bouffe le jeu tout le
monde en parle un mois avant qu'on
commence le foot et clotilde
l'agroalimentaire guillemets c'est
passionnant moi c'est vraiment mon sujet
de prédilection en entrepreneuriat parce
que tu es ce que tu manges que tu bois
et ses personnels le team et sa note à
12tu laval l'autre c'est comment et
quand j'entends le plus personnel que tu
m'as fait mieux non moi je suis très
excité par toutes les innovations qu'il
y en a beaucoup au québec
ouais c'est ça c'est ça que j'allais
dire en plus stylé lait de soya ou de
même le tough ultime succès ce qui
m'intéresse plus à 20 de la bourse de
tunis soyeuse broderie en rupture de
stock du cash de quoi ces fous qui les a
créés l'agriculture est en train de se
faire de révolutionner parce que des
grains justement un peu plus spécifique
c'est pas facile de produits c'est la
grosse cas mais on en finisse le nous
ont vendu du hors-jeu malte et pourquoi
ou et il fait quelques mois
c'est le fun puis puis ça fait aussi td
ça fait évidemment des choses plus
durable que c'est quelque chose qui doit
être intéressés la durabilité
comment on est capable en tant que ben
en fait toutes les entrepreneurs qui
sont qui se peuvent se diriger vers une
technique qui est plus responsable
bateau est obligatoire s'il sait même
plus qui peuvent se diriger c'est que si
tu penses en affaires il faut que ce
soit déjà d'après première priorité
je ne peux plus on à ce moment est cité
en affaires déjà il faut que tu
t'adaptes en réalité le tyran j'entends
le connaître le succès en affaires puis
détruire la planète s'apaise succès
comme la plus contre-productif
quand j'espère quel monde en tête c'est
parce que je propose la majorité ou plus
mais au québec en tout cas parce que
pascal gros problème c'est que souvent
on comprend la réalité convient qui on
se dit bête tout le monde ça doit être
ça mais depuis je donne souvent
l'exemple du risque l'âge nous c'est
important mais on le sait que c'est
important mais tu sais il ya plusieurs
milliards d'êtres humains que quand on
se lève le matin la seule priorité c'est
de trouver quelque chose à manger donc
le risque là chez le dernier de leurs
soucis infecté je crois que tous et
toutes ces problèmes sociaux ou
environnementaux sont aussi très humain
de ceux ci avaient moins d'inégalités
peut-être on aurait moins besoin de
recycler parce que c'est les personnes
qui sont dans la merde on va se dire
prendrait pas des choix des fois
catastrophique pour la planète mais qui
embaucheront le fret ou sinon c'était
des fois des choix c'est juste des
seules ambitions obligations à des
enfants qui mangent donc ouais c'est
même complexe que juste prendre d'être
ton petit bout de papier puis le mettre
dans un dans un bac de recyclage
ouais outils faire des choix éthiques
toujours dans ce que tu achètes des fois
ça se peut que sa poche et qui donne les
moyens aux gens de faire des choix
éthiques qui vont les faire le team qui
composent choisi mais il faut il faut il
faut faire comprendre que c'est pas
juste que c'est par des micros gestes
qu'on fait une grande différence mais si
tout le monde fait le micro geste là il
ya vraiment une différence je te crec
twh au pessimisme est irréaliste
chacun pense à soi même ce qui peut être
compréhensible ou si on me donne raison
mathis est important d'avoir un point de
vue surtout quand une dépense de
l'argent qui est apte à travailler
d'autres têtes grandes avancées sur
l'argent qui serait forme normale
programme sus de l'argent bâti essai de
d'avoir un maximum d'impact sur une
question pour un entrepreneur de retour
sur investissement
mais comme moi j'achète des noix prenant
mais je sais très bien que marie-josée
démarche extrêmement sérieuse est serré
et
ben tu y vas chez nous pays doit avoir
pour 5000 pièces d'une once de noix puis
celle des produits qualité en plus
infectés de loin je privilégie sa queue
un produit comme son look est juste là
pour exister tant de production là pour
être leur métier mais ton jeu que je
trouve que c'est une bonne une bonne
question à se poser team et on mange
achèterait un t-shirt éthiques
avant d'acheter un cliché de fast
fashion mais il va me coûter deux fois
et demi le prix laitiers puis comment
est ce que on n'est pas ce qu'on sait
que le changement va être lent si ça va
ça va passer par mettons faut augmenter
la demande pour les trucs est il que le
prix descende si nécessaire mais ce
qu'on fait pour accélérer ce processus
là qu'un conte et up against de claques
en ce moment en tant qu en tant qu manu
thétys qui s'apprend des changements qui
viennent d'en haut parce que je compte
je suis d'accord que la décision
individuelle a quand même un impact
puisqu'elle l'a chaque réalité chacun sa
grimace et surtout surtout comment est
ce qu'on fait est ce qui est ce qu'il
faut mais ton justement que dès que le
gouvernement décide de mettre ont donné
des subventions à des entreprises qui
font une transition vers un modèle qui
plus vert pour être capable de diminuer
le prix fixé quoi mettons là je te dirai
je te dirais qu'il ya plein de réponses
là mais en gros mois selon moi un des
gros problèmes c'est la surconsommation
tu es le t-shirt à deux pièces et demie
le temps n'a pas besoin de 18 ans
devrait en amoureux les vêtements nombre
de chaussures
j'ai bien trop de chaussures ouais mais
je lave ou non mais c'est pas ce que tu
veux pas moi je prends un gars qui
donnent des leçons mais je le vois comme
un alcoolique ce qui est alcoolique bon
mois il s'est dit
la première démarche vers l'acquisition
encore monstrueux mais le fait du dollar
c'est toujours si tout le monde se met à
acheter quelque chose il va baisser le
prix donc là aussi c'est un peu comme ce
sachet qui tourne autour ça que mais le
gros gros point je crois c'est que c'est
d'arrêter là d'avoir une discussion
d'extrême c'est que dans un sujet comme
ça c'est soit l'autre sur la planète a
mis en chantier
un dubois du lait d'avoine puis de
l'autre côté c'est ben ça c'est du
n'importe quoi tu t'achètes trop écope
quant à ben est agréé fantasy l'homme
est ce qu'on peut se rejoindre au milieu
d'avoir un max comme moi j'essaie au
maximum d'encourager sur les produits
locaux soient des produits
d'entrepreneurs locaux
mais ensuite mais je ne peux pas mais
pour moi un match est plié 5 puis pour
de vrai j'ai beaucoup discuté à trouver
des vêtements qui seront faites au
québec par des entrepreneurs des
entreprises québécoises tout la maman
d'anne et aussi plusieurs fois je me
suis cool on va te falloir que je me
lance une campagne vêtements souvent
c'est seul camp et les produits
d'ailleurs tous mes produits ont été
inventés presque comme ça dans mon cas
je le fais plaisir avant tout donc il ya
vraiment un
une complexité dans cette affaire là
mais je crois que c'est très tôt il faut
que dix quand tu commences à consommer
et y est ce que j'ai besoin de six
t-shirt ou ce que je peux en avoir 3 mai
un qui est éthique à cause du dollar
bien cause aussi de l'espace que ça
pompe sa caméra qualité qui vont durer
plus longtemps est rappelé aux acheteurs
japonais comme son prennent beaucoup
plus longtemps la qualité du prix ça
c'est ce c'est hachette
ma femme avait acheté moi ça fait 15 ans
chez à carreaux elle avait 20 ans le 24
ans et elle m'avait acheté un cadeau la
première année puis elle avait comme t
on à réponse est mais pour une raison
quelconque mm et j'espère qu'elle
continue les l'amour mais c'est ça
tiago qui est un porte documents on en
sait qu'on a lancé ensemble un porte
documents cuir italien l'avait été en
effet manqué ma femme et elle avait été
deux mois en italie au tout début de
notre relation et je vis tous les jours
encore 15 ans tous les jours ni voyage
voyage un voyage en chine chez nous mais
ils voyageaient il ya vosges à travers
le monde cette affaire là dans les
avions des trains tout ce que vous
voulez puis fonctionner même si elle
avait payé juste pas moins 800 dollars
et c'est le meilleur 800 dollars
cependant la question de cash flow
est-ce que tu aujourd'hui sans donner de
l'argent mais seul mon père ça a été un
moment marquant dans ma vie parce que
moi moi aussi je suis pas du genre à
avoir beaucoup d'affaires mais chose que
j'ai j'ai su la rigueur des choses de
qualité
puis mon père a mené il y avait des
souliers de travail avec lui territoire
et l'opt le médecin puis il est tout le
temps sur ses pieds matricule tenté
d'allumer externe cette affaire le puis
il y avait une part de souiller que
durer 15 puis sa paire de souliers déjà
en cuir l'été puis à la fin était et est
morte c'est quand il a décidé d'acheter
notre paire de souliers et acheter
exactement mêmes souliers c'est clair
des solides coûte cher le team est qui
qui ont tôt fait quinze ans il lui est
porté à tous les jours pendant 15 ans
puis a décidé de changer de souliers de
racheter la même part de l'état sens que
si c'est parce que tu vois une
entreprise de fast fashion qui font
littéralement maintenant il
ils font ils achètent les tissus en asie
et il coulait dessus pour faire des
tubes des patrons sur les bateaux c'est
de la poésie n'est pas ce que tu savais
moi quand j'étais plus jeune
j'habite en france puis j'ai travaillé
aux haras sur les champs elysées on
recevait quatre fois par jour du nouveau
stock nuit 4
au lieu d'être comme ça c'est comme ça
tu sais ce que c'est une boutique gens
qui que tout est ce que tous les
touristes arabes parce que celui de 8
heures du matin
oui cette chance on faisait des ventes
des fois de 200 et 300 mille euros d'un
journée dans la chaussée saint pierre et
de zahra sachant utiliser des quatre
étages pour toute la famille y en avait
un jeune femme
je travaillais je suis célibataire jésus
19 20 on se demande comment te
rencontrer au moins j'ai revenu ici mais
ouais c'est fou c'est fou c'est fait
et côté et en même temps celui qui est
celui qui a rien à se reprocher lance la
première pierre
moi je te crois que c'est vraiment ça le
truc c'est que c'est important d'en
parler sans donner de leçon
c'est parce qu'il ya des achats que je
proviens genre mais j'aurais pu acheter
ce que j'ai fait par après soyaux que
ces dégâts ici
puis c'est une monte éco responsable à
qui est qui qui fonctionne à l'énergie
solaire
nous sommes et l'argent revient au god
is it est un mejia après l'important
c'est de la démarche que tu entreprends
sur un long terme s'il faut juste faire
un achoppent c'est fini je me rassure je
me réconforte en quelques points où la
bouffe vous ouvrez mon frigo c'est
presque 100 % québécois pour tourner
parce que sage
j'ai un attachement particulier donc
voilà on essaie d'avancer
ouais ce qui est une bonne ce qui est ce
qui est une bonne étape dans le fond
c'est ce qui est le but le l'objectif
vers lequel on doit aller mais
effectivement que
situationnelle à capable et au pardon
épicerie au havre ils mettront vos de
produits bio québécois
c'est une bonne décision dans une
semaine mais où aller au marché jean
talon au marché atwater et il valait
peut-être un tout petit peu moins de
choix aux univers mail et et nous on est
là deux fois semaine je me méfie et
célia quand plus effectivement jean
gluten à la maison donc très souvent
baissé les producteurs locaux des
produits de la nature nature par les
céréales quelques pas de gluten donc
donc c'est sûr que si c'est une démarche
qu'on fait mais je crois qu'il faut
donner l'exemple
110 110 regarde moi je fais juste ça
mais regarde moi je fais ma part
et puis commençons par l'hôtesse qu'on
peut commencer quelque part
mais on ne dit pas fausse route
justement un faisant foi nous a fait
tout à l'extérieur un important système
modèle là parce que j'imagine qu'ils
veulent sans temps on devait croire les
médias
ça commençait des années 60 et 105 ch
quartier extrêmement pauvre et
problématiques maintenant à la scène
jeunesse dans les années 60 vous avez
des usines légaux cagney des très très
bon salaire et quand et où la
mondialisation qui a ouvert quand on a
accepté d'accélérer les échanges entre
pays surtout pour faire de la politique
politiques m'ont un peu de donner un peu
de tout à tout le monde
belle à ceux qui avaient ont perdu et
c'est là que ça une grosse problème
accepter que ça n'existe plus
aujourd'hui
ou presque plus des jobs avec la réalité
d'aujourd'hui on a 45 abdallah dans des
usines
[Musique]
c'est comme ça qu'ils à tapis c'est
aussi pour ça que les femmes ont été
obligés de retourner au travail
maintenant je remercie le team vers un
métier avant un salaire pouvait s'offrir
une famille nombreuse
aujourd'hui tu es deux jeunes
professionnels qui vient du permis sa
vie t'as pas d'enfant tu peux pas tache
manquons d'eau à montréal fait que le
coût de la vie notre salaire notre
réalité économique personnelle n'a pas
suivi le coût de la vie ça crée des
inégalités
ces inégalités la se voit de plusieurs
manières des quartiers qui avant allait
très bien qu'ils sont devenus très
pauvres comme saint john et des pays qui
exploitent leur manque pour faire la
piasse c'est quand tu achètes en chine
il y à quelques usines correct meteosat
en langue anglaise mais croit que la
chine c'est peut-être le mauvais exemple
parce qu'il ya tellement eu de
projecteur sur eux puis sont tellement
devenu anguilles une vraie économie qu
il soit chemin au pakistan watch out the
watcher les conditions fecteau chute à
dix pièces qui coule
m il quelqu'un qui a été ici les autres
je veux pas voir comment dans les
secondes qui s'écoulent nos frais c'est
quoi ce monde
ouais je t'ai entendu dire que tu voyais
un peu le pas ce que tout étudiant en
sciences politiques puis que tu voyais
un petit peu la politique comme comme la
gestion saine gestion des fonds publics
question puis comment est ce qu'on sait
pas ce qu on aime la convention et
cabrel a dit dubois qui nous parlaient
d'une d'une économie 100% autonome par
où on parle
ben moi je crois paul jeu complet
possible dans un monde mondialisé
ça c'est être un exemple de on va tout
de suite aux extrêmes
gabriel nadeau-dubois beaucoup de talent
définitivement je ne sais pas s'il croit
100 % à tous et à toutes les parties en
fait on a remarqué que tu fais pas un
parti d'un parti politique c'est
construire des compromis
je crois sincèrement que ya une réaction
à aux débordements du capitalisme
sauvage qu'on me rappeler mais d'aller
d'un extrême à l'autre extrême je reste
dans l'extrême un passé on peut pas se
rendre au milieu ou
maintien on développe un nouveau modèle
parce que lorsque problématique dans la
politique telle qu on la comprend
ou qu'on la voit c'est que c'est des
opinions personnelles ou de groupe ou de
groupuscules
mais la politique la science politique
sait comment gérer un état tu gères
panetta en pensant que voici ce que je
pense ce jeune en état avec des méthodes
de gestion avec ben réaliste le positron
peu après mais c'est sûr qu'il peut
avoir tes plein de comités spécialisés
pour les infrastructures du québec doit
faire comme ça mais avant tout moi ce
que je veux de nos politiciens c'est une
saine gestion de notre argent incluant
le leur une balle large c'est à nous
tous c'est comme notre maison
le québec puis la tangage du monde tu
vas voter pour sur les paye parce que
leurs salaires c'est tangage du monde
pour gérer ta business tu as raison je
m'engage employés d'administration ben
oui un pin
mais je comprends pas qu'on la voit
qu'on voit pas son genre on est
fataliste avec le poteau 7e pays crottés
mais moi c'est tout mais en plus tu es
décrotter ben non moi je les mènerai à
la forte une séquence puis je crois
qu'il faut mettre des règles il faut
réinventer bien entendu en permanence
tout parce que c'est dans le mouvement
que tu t'améliores m'est témoin je
convaincu qu il faudrait qu'il était pas
le droit de plus de deux mandats
consécutifs que tu dois aller voir la
vie ailleurs
la vraie vie et puis tu peux retourner
après cinq ans c'est moi ça serait
disons 10 en politique
cinq ans obligatoire dans soit plancher
des vaches pour que tu réalises c'est
vrai c'est ça la vraie vie on le voit
que ça donnerait des politiciens qui
sont la norme et il récemment dans
l'actualité on a vu les jantes et le
premier ministre qui sait plus comment
ça coûte un logement à montréal le team
rend compte qu'il ya un décalage ans qui
réalité deux fois oui je dirais qu'il a
échappé mais en même temps c'est une
question comme ça prix
la lettre de l'est sincèrement je ne
sais pas c'est une maman je suis
réaliste
j'achète quand même du lait 3 15,3
dollars j'imagine métissage mais c'est
un bon exemple que peut-être ça ferait
du bien à tous de revenir ce plancher
des vaches
il a travaillé dans le privé ou de
devoir trouver un job qu'après de
retourner parce que la politique ça
devrait pas une carrière ça ne devrait
pas être une carrière et d'ailleurs les
plus grands politiciens n'étaient pas
des praticiens de carrière il est urgent
de rené lévesque
que tu sois soudaine et souple en termes
d'hommes politiques
c'est un journaliste tu regardes j'ai
juste un bouchon mais pas les bouchons
c'est premier ministre bouchard lucien
bouchard lucien bouchard
mais son avocat tu regardes plein
d'exemples comme ça général de gaulle en
france mais c'est un général d'armée tu
regardes peut-être margaret thatcher
c'était pas une femme
de peu politique de carrière ou à une
galère merkel encore condamné quoi
qu'ils en font de cool mais t'es tu
t'attaches au pouvoir aussi parce que
c'est des personnes de tête il va le
gérer ils veulent la responsabilité
aussi
moi j'en connais beaucoup de députés de
toutes les parties la majorité sont là
vraiment pour la bonne raison
ouais mais la machine est lourde c'est
compliqué de vouloir réinventer le monde
pareil j'ai une bonne idée aurait calmes
toi mon gars a demandé une bonne idée
exactement s'était rapidement ça on s'en
tape les api pili pili un petit peu la
conviction pour les participants
qu'est-ce que je dois donner un suppo
d'euros tandis que ça a créé une espèce
de moules qui finalement des écoutes par
les petits j'ai pas l'impression que
c'est une vraie personne qui me permet
qu'un filtre ou qui n'en était même et
ça je te dirais qu'il ya un rôle aussi
des journalistes la qualité
journalistique à couvrir la politique
c'est moi je mettrais pas de député que
ce sit in pour des conneries en tant que
tu sais j'étais responsable la
journaliste non moi va me chercher le
vrai des bols témoins qui insultent
claude pour son petit shoot franchement
on paye le poste non celle ci je veux
voir un show divertissement j'allais sur
netflix ou sur rtl québec ou à la rue je
peux aller l'assemblée nationale
visiblement la politique s'insultent
intéressante et idées là dedans aussi
pied tantôt au ps je pose la question
est ce que est ce qui finalement la
politique c'est comme si comme gérer une
business mes skis inversement faire le
business et politique
oui absolument surtout quand atteint un
certain niveau parce que tu dois gérer
d'une manière ou créer un consensus des
sujets reja je veux faire une idée pige
la ramenant à gorges mon équipe plus
personne croit on trouve que c'est une
bonne idée
t'auras pas le meilleur des résultats
après ben toujours un budget comme le
new business
après tu gères d
des stress comme dans la politique après
tu dois convaincre un électeur un
consommateur c'est le même en plus oui
oui oui mon johnny est bon crois moi on
croit moyennement télécoms de vendre un
produit à un moment faire c'est un tâche
est une idée l'autre tu achète un
produit mais oui bien un certain niveau
aussi justement télé les les questions
et ses conteurs etc la tête un code en
dix mètres du poteau logique que tu te
donnes à toi même mais que tu insuffler
à l'entreprise nous on est depuis le
début de l'année un peu plus loin même
on a on est en plein de questions
stratégiques pour nos cinq prochaines
années t on face aux trois ou cinq ans
et puis on revoit nos ambitions nos
visions nos valeurs nos codes nos règles
les règles internes plus tout le monde
comme là nous on a fait les mercredis
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est mercredi
déconnecté donc on n'a pas des zones
patcher pas quoi là dans l'entreprise on
est en train de devenir fou
les vendredis l'été on a un horaire
d'été encore le vendredi à midi sauf
urgence bien sûr on essaie de fournir à
notre notre équipe le les meilleurs
outils pour pour être sain
premièrement humainement un humain sain
jetons à collex un point de collecte
fait la job qui va bien faire sa job
incluant moi parce que je tiens en péril
mon entreprise certain niveau city les
hommes les hommes et femmes d'affaires
influent au québec qui finissent par une
influence aussi absolument tirer
politique ou sorties qui deviennent ou
super santé publique moi qui parle tout
le temps à tête en courant je te demande
que les commerces la carotide transmet
ses salles à un impact dans la société
moi je crois qu'on a une responsabilité
je dis pas que j'impose pas aux
entrepreneurs qui veulent rester dans
leur tous de s'impliquer
moi je m'applique énormément pour les
causes qui à mes yeux sont très
importantes très inquiet avec la
fondation et à saint justin avec les
jeunes entrepreneurs gens fait puisque
passé avec les artistes locaux
les artistes absolument avec aussi une
certaine part de santé mentale ou est un
entrepreneur c'est pas toujours évident
même quand ça va bien et poursuit toute
ma démarche du télétravail mon livre mon
baladou cela parce que moi j'étais en
train de me foule
l'important champ top game on est plus
important producteur de spiritueux au
canada ça va bien plus que bien je
pourrais être un mantra vault bien
souvent c'était de la merde et non sur
le dérange zone de la mode pour moi dans
une baraque de trois étages autres
membres le cheikh imagine les autres
j'avais tous les outils pour réussir
j'ai raté lamentablement moi mais ma
transition télétravail juste pas compris
c'était quoi je crois et stages travail
chez soi même compliqué que ça y est
c'est le confort ou six états bulletin
zone c'est quand tu travailles tu vas
être à l'aise peu comme le chiendent
simpi moins c'est que c'est vraiment
carreaux qui m emmener m'a foutu dehors
de la maison du télétravail dupliquer en
panne parce qu'en plus merdique et
jeunes enfants il y avait paul il n'y
avait pas deux zones séparées comme moi
j'ai hâte il travaille il ya trois ans
quand j'ai acheté ma maison on a vidé
quand je dis videla il y avait juste les
quatre murs qui restaient puis avec
l'architecte m'a dit on veut séparer vu
que la business est à moi et à ma femme
on veut séparer la business de la
famille on ne veut pas de bureau à la
maison
erreur de ma fille fait lâcher je
travaillais et en plus au tout début
toutes les écoles cp interarmées de la
aujourd'hui l'envié mais dans le temps
victor y avait quatre amis charlotte
deux ennemis ma femme était enceinte de
six mois
bionic au boot avec mon oreillette
tu parles forte mon blouson bleu tout
qui est en train de se déplacer en pâte
patrouille paix des dinosaures c'est pas
le fun pour personne puis on est des
millions à avoir vécu ce trailer avec ou
sans enfants parce que c'était en face
tout mais c'est une autre réalité
mais alors moi ça a été catastrophique
comme lost et on a une très très forte
période parce qu'on a faite
désinfectants pour les mains
oui très rapidement c'est scott c'est
devenu un monstre en deux semaines la
cet enfant cordes ruine oui j'essaie
d'arrêter mais l'odeur c'est certains de
nos clients qu'ils ont encore une
certaine crainte
je peux comprendre au début mais c'était
juste les services essentiels et les
hôpitaux et les prisons et la saq se
désagrège sainte-justine soap et et par
après dans une des grandes entreprises
parce que tu peux fournir beaucoup pitié
on voit que c'est encore fragile
il ya encore une petite crainte on a
fait aussi des lingettes désinfectantes
et on a fait plein d'affaires fait que
moi je me retrouvais avec une entreprise
de spiritueux à gérer une transition de
télétravail
surtout nous tisser des bureaux a
tellement agréable nos bureaux et puis
là on se retrouve tout le monde chez soi
jeremic que c'est pas comment gérer ça
gérer plus de 700 mille litres de
désinfectant pour les mains on a reçu
une commande cette somme elle est à
seynod réaliste c'est pas réaliste faire
en palettes z os 7 800 à l'aide d'un
produit que 2 minutes avant d'avoir
l'idée j'aime pas c'est quoi un fake bas
de six ans en même temps et je crois que
ce qui m'a surtout accusé s'extrait en
urgence c'était comme moi un hôpital
m'appelle c'est pas comme dans trois
mois on a besoin c'est comme si on en
est là c'est comme s'épuisant détend
pandémie on va le savoir mais d'être en
urgence tout le temps l'idée est apparue
au moment où ce que te livre
ta première région d'ici là aucun
rapport débile et d'ailleurs je suis
super content de vous dire parce que je
les fait avec mon chef des finances et
opérations
pierre alexandre et ensuite avec
stéphane et magali sur toulon cet effet
ni ticket parce qu'on voulait pas
déconcentré tout le reste de l'équipe on
a quand même et puis alexandre a été
nommé hier le site un comptable le cpe
de l'année grâce à cause de cette
expérience l'autre 40000 cpa y avait je
suis vite lauréats par par région puis
j'en suis extrêmement fier parce que je
les ai vus ou est vraiment bravo peur
parce que je l' ai vu de mes yeux vu
et quand on travaille des vrais 18
heures par jour c'est juste pour vous
mettre en contexte 18 mars
ça fait six jours on est en télétravail
en pandémie je lis défaire du
désinfectant
là je suis dans mon sous-sol en
confinement obligatoire en pandémie
on a lancé une entreprise de
désinfectant pour les mains où il
fallait développer une recette mais on
savoir c'était quoi développer une
recette avoir une approche bastion de
santé canada trouver des bouteilles
c'est pas du tout de suite trouvé des
bouteilles design des années voici des
années une étiquette un avant
l'approbation de santé canada risque est
trouvé des pompes trouver des bouchons
trouver un embouteilleur parce que très
rapidement on n'a pas pu suivre le
volume est tous à 1 dijon je sais même
pas comment j'ai comme je suis je sais
pas je me réveille la piste est comme à
lens pauvres est un rêve a rassuré plus
ça prouve qu'il ya une urgence piqué
c'est comme on fait des pieds et des
mains pour sa fonction c'est sûr mais
steam et on en attend en entendant ce le
pis je me dis comment c'est si une
entreprise privée peut avoir cette ce
temps de réaction l'aide est capable de
renverser de bord de même pourquoi est
ce que on pendant tellement longtemps
fait comme à londres plus de masse qu'on
n'est pas près de trouver démasquer on
est au coeur de conceptualiser des
masses philo ça a duré à peu
trois mois où est ce qu'ils on se
faisait dire qu'il n'y avait pas de
masse comme et pourquoi pourquoi on
n'est pas pourquoi on ne peut qu'être
d'appliquer ce principe le un atout à
tout seul il faut il faut une guerre
mondiale où une pandémie pour changer
les choses parce qu'ils jour là je me
suis dit ma tante est une compagnie
dessus qui décident de flipper juin 25
cents comme ça nous sommes si ça ce
serait plus mais je dirai la vérité
comme nous on est une compagnie d'alcool
l'alcool était en rupture de stock
tian n'avait pu s quand on se rappelle
qu'on était géographiquement mal placé
pour la pandémie dans le sens où toute
l'asie toute l'europe était déjà en
pleine crise et donc avait déjà commandé
tout mon argent avant l'amérique du nord
fait cno les derniers salissent le sur
alibaba points comme la honte et dernier
essai de trouver quelque chose
combien discuter tu vois j'ai plusieurs
entrepreneurs que je connais qui sont
assez atteint très rapidement il y en
aurait plus de gens il y en a de plus
l'alcool a monté six fois en trois
semaines de prix c'est parce qu'il ya
des rapaces pendant le temps de lancer
sous les pires moments mais met
clairement par exemple servient l'achat
local pour les entrepreneurs d'ici dit
clairement puis moi je voudrais toute ma
vitesse et les pme du québec qui ont
souri québec les visières de tête
phénomène des points au dessus d'un peu
partout du désinfectant ne peut partout
on ne peut pas les seuls franchement des
infirmières les profs les profs mans est
allé à l'école sachant que c'est une
pandémie comme 34 devant toi pilotes
essayent de police très site essaient de
faire ta job tu as ta famille chez toi
tu stresses toi même te trompes possible
du bonhomme qui peuvent croire les profs
là qu'était j'espère qu'on est debout le
rapport aussi la baisse on espère tout
le monde aime les dames jeudi d'âme
parce que là c'est pleinement ma fille à
ses jeunes et dames et négocié dans ces
pays les éducatrices jeunesse et l'autre
se voit c'est quiquet les postes
névralgiques
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on pensait puis
les postes névralgiques on se rend
compte que c'est pas nécessairement les
plus valorisées aps les mieux payés de
l'ancienneté où c'est ça ça il faut
vraiment que ça c'est ce que je vous
dirais là j'ai déjà un truc là de fokine
plate là mais parce que c'est des postes
dits dauphin soins infirmiers majorité
de femmes prof majorité de femmes
encore plus je crois primaires et je
rends cpe majorité de femmes c'est
triste comme quand germaine et robben
mais non la présence habitent et
maintenant tout le monde sait jamais si
c'est elle et j'ai pas mal et pompiers
laqué qui était tout aussi important
même si je crois qu'il se serait fait
entendre peut-être je tords j'espère à
votre médecin il me semble que que des
jobs que ils ont ce qu'ils veulent très
rapidement versus l'importante commande
importants mais l'importance de ce
qu'ils amènent surtout principales
villes de la santé de l'éducation c'est
les deux grands piliers python
télétravail dit ça a été horrible put a
visiblement appris beaucoup d'étapes à
ce qui était écrit qui fait un balado
sur le sujet doit fac-ci quoi les
grandes leçons de tortis risque
sérieusement moi j'adore vivent un échec
parce que je j'ai beaucoup de défauts le
mais une de mes qualités c'est que quand
je viens échec justement sit in et de
comprendre pourquoi j'ai pas réussi que
j'apprends quelque chose de vraiment le
fun après et donc le télétravail mon
livre comment ces conseils astuces
experts pour réussir santé travail c'est
que j'ai approché neuf experts pour
disséquer mon échec je gagne quoi
sécurité était un ergonome c'est juste
la position c'est plus moi j'suis super
5 vous allez rire m les bureaux qui
montre un ben ce créneau une belge pouce
de trop grandes
oui c'est parce que c 'est pas encore
atteint les chaises sont pas
nécessairement fait de reprendre ensuite
j'ai approché un psychologue
parce qu'on s'entend plus grands tabous
de la société c'est la santé mentale la
sortie mycologique
pourtant tout le monde peut s'accrocher
au moment mobile absolument psychologue
devrait être obligatoire de nouveau
s'élever
c'est dommage que ça coûte cher ces
mobilisations se trouve ça ça fait du
bien par là quelqu'un de fort de former
puis deux
dans des mains amies ce point par an
puisque je vois pas de jugement lui il
voit une personne avant de partir
d'après moi juste aidé à la primaire en
fait c'est ça existe aussi public c'est
juste que c'est impossible de manquer sa
cible et il va falloir ça bouge à
l'épuisement professionnel est encore
pire qu'avant
après j'ai approché une personne pour
l'entraînement physique tu es une autre
personne bref j'ai approché tellement de
monde parce que je voulais comprendre
puisque j'ai appris mais ce que j'ai
compris hein c'est qu'il faut c'est le
truc le plus fou que j'ai appris la j'ai
cliqué monétique 50 clips comme au shit
je le découvrais que je dirais quand on
sait que ça fait comme 30 50 ans chip
combien d'années qu'on m'ait qu'on fait
une obsession sur le bonheur et la
croissance personnelle tesio grand
intérêt à se comprendre regarder le
soleil c'est pourquoi le chauffeur s'est
offerte exactement mieux manger pour des
bonnes raisons mais pourquoi mais on a
comme fait comme s'il 50 % du reste de
notre vie n'existait pas le bonheur
professionnel
moi qui bordélique dans ma tête mais qui
fait plein de trucs mais t'es chez moi
c'est des fois je cherche mais plus le
même mail j'ai réalisé mon avec le
terrain j'ai besoin de ma bulle au
travail je ne savais même pas ce qu'ils
ne seraient plus maison dans ma misère
qu'ils ont commis 24 24 je savais même
pas que j'avais besoin d'être dans ma
bulle d'un espace d'un espace je savais
pas que j'avais besoin
de luminosité naturelle elle j'ai acheté
toutes les ligues ont fait fortune
écumant les lans toutes les lampes la
salle debout de deux côtés en arrière
matt hagan
non ce n'est la bonne vieille manette
wii c'est ça et puis moi je veux truc du
lait je suis très gadget succès et donc
j'ai découvert l'écran coville un
courbet nakata changé ma vie
pour une raison quelconque je sais
pourquoi je me suis beaucoup tillé
malheureusement il ya un prix à tout
cela on veut centrer mais je me suis dit
j'ai besoin de ça pour être au top de ce
que je peux donner puis moi ma force
c'est les idées c'est multi décès multi
projets je comprends pourquoi parce que
plus on fait moins tu dois perdre de
temps en temps à ses vrais gens aiment
le foot anglais muette trucs pour ça je
me disais c'est nommé nouveau bureau de
ses cheveux que mon bureau perso soit
aussi un studio parce que ma vie est
tellement devenu studio is et puis la
même radio canada tous les mercredis je
fais ça de mon bureau en r&d et puis
faut que je monte mon micro faut que je
mange je devenais un technicien
audiovisuel je peux pas un plus de
maggio puisque je peux pas une job je
peux pas affecté sa changé drastiquement
avec moi j'ai besoin fait qu'il ya une
sainte trinité en télétravail le confort
physique en termes d'ergonomie
c'est vraiment bien installé humains
pohdh crocheta table de cuisine nous le
concret dans ton lit ou huawei s'est
écrasé dans ton lit et m
oui c'est cool de semaine mais après
terrain volts assassiné le l'activité
physique ça bouge beaucoup moins parce
que mille et une raisons mais l'activité
physique
moi je combine avec la santé mentale
parce que je crois que les deux sont
indissociables
notre définitivement parlé un petit peu
plus tôt alors la mécanique la la
mécanique bébel la mécanique corporelle
un plan la tête et l'autre côté
sérieusement c'est un très très très
difficile travail à faire sur soi même
pour se donner des limites savoir qu'on
aurait été développé une méthode de
travail te convient à toi tu as la
chance d'être chez toi maintenant c'est
une chance la marquise mon bet sétois
développe une routine pour toi vite fait
at war et pas genre un one size fits ans
et ça marche jamais les soins de suite
fait que fais tu sais moi je sais
vraiment au top après ben tout un chacun
peut y en a qui aiment travailler
peut-être avec la musique woodson fait
lutte
mais même en mettant la question que je
me pose c'est le côté le contact humain
dans mon expérience est assez important
et métiers nous mettons on travaille
pour le studio en studio en commençant
bien on habite ensemble fait qu'on est
souvent de règne de se parler de bandes
et des idées de commerce est c'est pire
c'est que je m'imagine quelqu'un qui
tente d'enterrer travail puis que ses
seuls contacts humains sieeom petit zoom
jean a bpa qui comparaît de sommet comme
quand on t'envoie d'énergie
habituellement cas qu'on se parle en ce
moment tu mens renvoi mais quand quand
en a pas qui revient laudebat épuisant
s'épuisant affectés sur youtube une
solution à ce contact sérieusement et
jamais la chose qui manque à personne en
côte
j'ai toujours été entouré énormément de
personnes autant dans l'entreprise
autant que je suis allée conférence plus
qu'à passer avant la pandémie
là j'en fais énormément métier je me
regarde dans un break à 4-1 d'une foule
très piquant les entreprises disons que
j'ai une conférence demandent à leurs
montres de fermer leur miller sont leurs
caméras je parle à moi-même pendant une
heure et demi devant mais on ne sent
rien recevoir sans rire sa reddition
sont inscrits à ma propre blague ça ça
va mal tout monument mais moi ça me
manque terriblement l'humain la cfu par
exemple côté plus perso pouvoir coucher
mes enfants est réveillé mes enfants
tous les matins jeunes enfants voient
maintenant je sais mieux de la loterie
moi parce que tu veux je voyageais
beaucoup avant tu peux pas atteindre les
plus hauts sommets en ayant une vie
normale on va faire tout de suite et
donc fautif à ce que peu de personnes
acceptent de faire ou peuvent faire les
sacrifices à sa crise préfinale sacré
c'est pas genre je veux finir plus tard
ce soir si je vais finir plus tard pour
les 15 prochaines années
puis me plains pas tous un choix
personnel
ça passait pas et que c'est facile
cadres ou écoulé ou s'ils écoutent nous
on n'a pas de sens si on a développé un
modèle où il ya deux pdg s'il pdg de la
maison de ma vie et moi je suis pdg de
l'entreprise
parce que trois jeunes enfants en plus
ça va nous compliquer c'est là une
réalité logistique différente et ça pour
moi je suis extrêmement reconnaissant de
la pandémie de pouvoir avoir avec common
raffalli et huit mois
ben moi j'ai passé huit mois avec lui
ouais ce que des pôles que d'un
agresseur sexuel l'homme est au bureau
n'est pas parce que je veux ou prouvé
que j'étais cool match croule sous les
dossiers le zonage doit le choix le tse
m'emmener et puis il faut des fois il ya
des délais hors de mon contrôle
quand j'étais obligé de théâtre en
affaires c'est de la danse la danse seul
ça peu mais c'est souvent en duo
effectif si la personne a besoin d'une
réponse ou d'un piège pas tout bloquer
mais je suis vraiment pas un exemple moi
jégu je sais que je suis vraiment too
much logique
vraiment là on travaille j'essaye de me
calmer comme l'a enfin balado on est
quel jour on est 10 heures 40
jamais j'aurais non c'était le soir
parce que je travaille mais on avait
déjà écrit même à ton équipe
ouais tiens la pente hac et puis que
écoute je suis bombardée
moi je suis bombardée je sais vous êtes
très suivi vous au 6 mai soit les 3 400
messages par jour
quarante demandes valadou par sa mère
c'est comme je les vois même plus jeunes
merci adjoint de maintenant qui sait
malheureusement que casser le cou jack
et je retombe à le tu vois que le monde
est important autour de toi mais n'ont
cessé moi je veux prendre cette pandémie
comme une wii capcom j'ai 40 ans jeune
pour me faire dire est ce que j'avais
besoin de rouler à 220 ou est-ce que
mieux organisé je peux rouler à 140
moins que déjà 2 juin boylan de la 42e
place mais est tout aussi productif fait
que je fais une obsession sur la
productivité maintenant un personnel le
portrait je ne touche pas aux dictateurs
en affaires mais pour moi j'en dictateur
parce que je vois que chaque gain que je
vais chercher ben c'est du gain peau
pour ma famille c'est justement la
priorité au sol d'air puis cette
obsession la excuse comment ça se
concrétise
ben je te dirai que je travaille
énormément sur moi même pour pouvoir un
peu défaire toutes mes idées préconçues
de ce que je crois peut-être avec raison
peut-être que j'ai tort de ce que je
dois faire pour continuer à réussir en
affaires
avoir des nouvelles idées la première
chose moi je vends un psychologue
industriel
je sais que le web est un psychologue
est spécialisée dans pour le monde du
travail ou
on a tous des vitres on va se dire mais
je suis pas quelqu'un de déprimer je
suis quelqu'un d'extrêmement privilégié
heureux en santé mais je me pose
beaucoup de questions j'ai beaucoup de
sentiment de culpabilité envers beaucoup
moins de plus à prôner me mettais envers
ma famille dit quand je parte elle dans
le taxi sq
ok j'y allais repas je fais sur notre
sourire puis fin que je déprimais je
galère en importe
et puis comment mener durant de nanterre
dans ta bulle ça ça pèse lourd t il
serait ce qu'un alexis aussi l'anxiété
le presque contrôler ça j'ai recommencé
l'entraînement
moi qui a jamais été quelqu'un qui qui
pensaient peut-être fouiner voix c'est
quoi la proche du yoga ou la méditation
je commence à lire le bouquin les crois
tu sais je ne veux que tout le monde
s'affaire le que tout le monde parle
depuis à peu près 15 ans le web ça pour
juger par lui-même
je suis non mais tu sais je pense qu'il
prenne un fort qui m'attire mais dont tu
m'attire pas pipe je vous avais tu étais
j'ai lancé ça j'avais 24 et 40
je rêve de le même trois enfants avec si
avec ça je n'avais rien à perdre j'ai
pas tout à perdre
je considère que j'ai toujours rien à
perdre parce que finalement ce sujet la
santé ce qu'aurait khimar amis aussi
mais bref je veux m'améliorer au
quotidien la bouffe le truc breslau cg
salaire comme bailleur claire lamarche
mais non mais mais cet échec est
quadrillée au travail des plus
productifs
ces sortes constat c'est que
et puis toi tu content de moi mais pour
de vrai pendant juste manger moins deux
portions de viande
moi j'étais un carnivore fini non plus
de cette portion de vient encore une
fois pas aller à l'extrême arrangements
je suis bien après chacun ses croyances
le browser sonné mais mais juste ça je
vois tu changes le lendemain est ce que
c'était un symbole
je sais pas mais si ça marche tant mieux
et plus de lait que c'est des trucs
comme ça
j'essaye andré l'histoire on attendait
son entrepreneur si j'avais lu le livre
et la mosquée c'est le steak homme qui
va hanter un peu le fait qu'ils
faisaient des vingt heures par jour
qu'elle ait cherché de hot dog ou
d'aucune de bolt au bas de la rue
revenait contient de travail et puis si
ça fonctionnait pour lui m'ont attiré me
semble ça peux pas te conseille de te
dirais que ça fonctionne pour lutter
j'aimerais savoir vraiment si ça
fonctionne et énormément c'est de
fonctionner malgré son nom mais c'est
facile de c'est très facile d'oublier
ouais et c'est comme quand tu écoutes
moi j'aime écouter big est arrivé nature
qui me fait me divertit beaucoup il ya
du très bon contenu et il ya oublié je
crois parce que souvent les conseils qui
donne et oublient que huit personnes
dans son équipe à temps plein jeu en
face à hypo stick personne peut faire 40
pause par jour avec du contenu différent
puis écrire un blog qui est sexy pendant
l'événement est cette baisse est due 20
heures par jour j'allais fait plus que
passer je te garantis que c'est presque
une obligation au départ définitive pas
une manière pour réussir sur le long
terme
on est tous semaine mon à 2,5 heures qui
flanche
on a tous une fatigue mentale on a tous
du monde qui nous abandonnent autour
d'une agréable d'être avec une personne
qui est un cinglé du travail oui
cependant ce qu'ils étaient ce qui est
triste un peu puis ça je fais le cheval
je fais le lien parce que j'ai vécu six
ans parce que moi j'ai fait sport-études
j'ai joué très haut niveau - au basket
ben tu es plus je m'entête dans les
niveaux les ligues plus cost était
presque devenu de la science mon affaire
ce que je mangeais s'était posée ce
qu'elle était
tout est fait c'est pas trés pas que
c'est pas agréable mais pour aller
chercher cette fraction de seconde mais
ça prend ça prend des extrêmes ça prend
finalement la même chose en fait dans la
bretelle domaine plutôt à haut niveau
plus faut que tu ailles discipline qui
comprennent la force de l'équipe
il faut ensuite au tour des meilleurs ça
cette offre puisque quand un
entrepreneur c'est très égoïste est un
emploi parce que c'est ton idée que tu
vas faire tes convaincu ça va marcher
tabarnak c'est pas mal à donner à ces
des performances et qu'après il faut que
ça devienne nous absolument mêmes ça
peut même devenir c'est important des
fois que ça devienne eux ont raison moi
j'étais dans ma business - ça c'est
vraiment celui qu'on a vite plus qu'elle
montre gauchy j'aurais fait une erreur
et ça c'est vraiment cool à vif métier
moi je prends toujours l'exemple de
youth en bouteille ou sandbox plus grand
joueur de tous les temps au volant est
rayé avec michael jordan est pas loin et
d'autres savaient qu'il ya des centaines
de milliers de personnes à faire le
monde qui peuvent courir le 100 m en 11
secondes et il y en a peut-être vin
qu'ils courent en vote de second set
seconde là ça prend dix ans pour pour un
millième de la population allait les
chercher
physiothérapeute psychologue en
tabarnouche la messe sportive de haut
niveau une autre des psychologues la
bouffe la tête autant ils font des
efforts physiques autant le repos
l'autre côté un ultra important us font
traiter tous les jours de leur vie l'a
rejoint sur le muscle ils vont dans des
laboratoires pour leur position est ce
qu'il faut puis des fois ils vont
travailler sur un muscle du dos juste
pour un appui droits pour pouvoir nous
tout de foule quand moins essayer c'est
un char la main là que je considère
comme un bon ami et coutts et des
machines de guerre dans ses cales fait
qd et malheureusement pour atteindre
l'extrême donc très peu fasse un peu d'
extrême là il faut pas que tu tombes
dans l'extrême sur un long terme ce
pauvre
pour un athlète c5 en invitant un effet
ce que ces trois ans la moyenne de ce
massacre le record 10 ans 15 ans pour
trois ans que c'est pas le jeu tout le
monde professionnel par là j'aurais pu
perdre la nfl
sauf la cour de la khl d'après son
massacre it c'est l'extrême et c'est
l'extrême équilibre dans le fond
notamment donné il faut que tu tombes
dans ses skis japon et d'athlètes qui va
dire je m'entraîne battre par jour puis
à 4,4 euros parmi les jeux c'est
impossible sociaux exact puis c'est
comme le seul le dernier 5 pour 5 prend
90 % ton erreur le tir dans le fond
c'est sur la route du 82 kw même
effectivement parce que tu sais quoi moi
j'ai arrêté le basket j'ai abandonné le
basket je l'utilisé le terme ça me prend
20 ans utilisé le vrai accepté ouais
j'ai abandonné parce qu'elle n'était
plus le meilleur dans mon équipe je
crois pas je crois que je tape une mère
qui l'a définitivement pas le meilleur
mais je crois que c'est ça qui m'a
démotivés qui me fait croire que bon
c'est plus vraiment penser à autre chose
je sais pas vraiment tout parce que
quand je connais mal ballon mais c'est
parce que moi j'ai eu le piège d'avoir
du talent moi j'étais très talentueux
mais j'avais pas d'éthique de travail
je serai le sextet ce qui est le cas
quand même de beaucoup de personnes
ouais il talents belges saran le talent
ça t'amène avec le meilleur de pee wee
du pee wee on va être là dessus
effectifs non mais m michael jordan qui
est moins c'est vraiment un modèle si
j'en ai un c'est une personne que 20
talent minimum mais karine éthique de
travail et que personne et donc c'est
pour ça que réussie parce qu'il sait
faire rejeter une nécessité par an
c'était pas le premier qui a été
sélectionné piste époque la stature à la
lebron james thomas kodjo dès ce matin
les grands mais c'est normal un bijou
mais normal puis jetez plus clip ça mais
pratique est tout le temps tout
tout tout tout le temps ouais c'est
alexander popov qui est un sprinter de
natation un russe puis son coach disait
que des talents comme alexander popov y
en avait qui courait tout les coins de
rue et ouais mais que y'en a pas qu'il y
avait le petit edge qui c'est qui qui
s'est rendue où il s'est rendu utile
mais c'est du talent ça existe le
partout le michael phelps pour aller
dans la natation a neigé soit lu un
article
des fois on est tellement vide à la
douce ballade au mes sources des fois
maintenant son pluri annoncé sur twitter
commence bien entendu j'ai lutté nico
feps dans son prime il ya été tous les
jours pendant huit ans 365 jours par
année à noël non j'ai nagé tous les
shows pris plus souvent qu'autrement
deux fois par jour ouais tous les gels
douche tous les jours pendant huit ans
alors moi mais crawford simon inclus
c'est vraiment un impressionnant content
d'avoir vécu ces moments à noter avec la
télé de voir ça parce qu'il ya eu 10 il
ya eu d d d exploit qui sont fait qu'on
a c'est qu'on les voit pas qu'on vive
comme un tournoi comme mon ami et elle
m'avait raconté
tu es le premier homme sur la lune mais
j'aime avoir été terrible c'est fou hein
nous banques ayant un doute qui habite
de red bull c'est pile c'est quoi qui a
pu être rouvert
par exemple j'aurais cru qui reste dans
l'univers dans l'univers public surtout
tellement à voir parce qu'à ramener il
sait combien à faire des vrilles qui
était comme vraiment qu'il ait pu
vraiment capable de stabiliser son
souffle que dans 90 contre moi c'est ça
y est comme perdu connaissance dans son
enfant avec moi je pense que ce que
l'oeil du avoir trop parlé du frac et
non massif civil a été tué et un des
plus l'exploit red bull que l'exploit du
golfe c'est une entreprise dans l'étude
de codes du marketing large
on t'offre abattre la même que celle à
battre parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est comme
quand tu tu réussis à faire presque a
brandi un moment ça sert à tout témoin
joint un gars en ski qui essaie une
pirouette qui se casse la gueule comme
cherche le logo red bull vidéo lui c'est
un truc extrême c'est red bull
c'est fort c'est un tour de force un
athlète en plein effort cénacle way
exemple vingt mille autres marques
donc je trouve ça super intéressant mois
les marques qu'ils deviennent des
moments puis ça moi c'est la teinte
ultime pour un entrepreneur en tout cas
moi qui est un entrepreneur sont
créatifs la toile et plusieurs tangente
mois les univers de marque ça me
passionne je fais je lis beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup là dessus c'est
tellement intéressant de voir la
naissance un de l'idée puis de voir
comment la traduc moi je voulais être
achetés que j'avais pas les bonnes je
pense que le patient soit cet architecte
macotakara existe la côtière qui ruine
tendre à eux
et c'est tellement bien finalement l'
architecture d'une marque
j'entendais aussi dire que que tout
roulait avec avec la compagnie crée des
moments puis c'est un peu dans cette
idée là de voir mettons une compagnie
comme red bull comme naïve et crée des
moments de faire comme moi aussi je veux
lancer dans l'univers de la marque
absolument quel est le processus de
reverser ses commettants l'idéation de
dire jouer si ce jeu vous formez vous
raconter quelques anecdotes comment j'ai
eu l'idée d'un produit ou d'une autre
comme cela nous allait mieux comprendre
mais c'est sûr que tu vas on n'en
produit plus on en produit ça
m'intéresse vraiment pourquoi
voilà trois dollars s'il vous plaît
nommé platz à faire là tandis que tu es
vendre le meilleur lait d'avoine parce
que j'ai eu l'idée avec marie-josée dans
un trip de sac à dos en mind et marjo
dit de preneurs et parce que elle est
très fan sur lavoine et je sais que on
achète son sac pour faire les led avoir
une raison très fan des extras moi c'est
en surfant autant c'est une de mes
meilleures amies dans la vie au temps
tant qu'entrepreneur chapeau mais c'est
quand les bottines suivent les babines
c'est un gauche la cei à 20h15 dans le
camp voulait vendre des graines de chia
pad et des baies de goji sécher ses
calmes qui croient en fait li li
bottines sont avant les babines ce que
c'est vraiment très les valeurs qui ont
été le bain avant les produits m mais je
rangeais ok y'a même pas de papillons et
des bottines
mais bergame un exemple cournoyer
parenthèse bicorps parce que c'est c'est
aussi prestigieux qu'on l'ait comme
l'impression balorre bicorps nous nous
entendons tous fait plus puissante en
ont fait un podcast factice un big up
c'est une
c'est une organisme de certification
disons le comme ça qui font en sorte que
tu dois remplir vraiment beaucoup de
critères qui sont considérés au jour
d'aujourd'hui puisqu'il faut toujours
regarder avec le jour d'aujourd'hui
comme étant respectueux dans ta démarche
entrepreneuriale autant d'un point de
vue environnemental autant après de vue
ressources humaines autant tu es tout la
patente la transparence là si le choix
des tons fournissant tout seul je suis
100% pur
cependant il ya certaines entreprises
qui le sont devenus pour le marketing ça
ça me dérange beaucoup parce que ça
enlève à ceux qui le sont vraiment une
importance et un signature et il y en a
qui clairement le sont devenus je
pourrais nommer parce que ça mérite pas
mais tu es certain groupe multinational
que ça me fait un peu rire l'autre bord
oui non oui évidement fiscale c'est
accepter maintenant ou optimisation
fiscale
moi je ferai attention mais jallet salle
à sa place pour les entreprises qu'ils
sont les façons les hommes comme une
agence que j'adore ici république une
agence de pub qui laisse quand même
quelque chose
ces gars là sont géniaux les 25 ans du
cirque ils sont comme des canidés
quel week end oui ils sont donc non je
suis 100 % pour les sens pour mais les
accréditations faut toujours faire
attention puis je veux pas être cynique
métier on se rappelle du du biologique
il ya dix ans j'étais tout petit rien ta
biologique
aujourd'hui il ya des il ya des
standards vraiment très ému je suis tant
qu'il ya de l'homme il ya de l'hommerie
puis j'ai toujours peur qui était repéré
des failles marque c'est ça je crois que
c'est encore plus puissant des dates big
up sans même l'avoir avant l'ascension à
ski à salt et je crois que ça c'est
comme il ya plus de babine j'ai débattu
le moment précis on revient au moment
bah c'est sûr que tu es comme les
canettes les prêtes à bord on a vraiment
été le le catalyseur de la renaissance
c'est très intéressant une business j'en
suis extrêmement fier parce que on a été
bon mais vraiment des premiers pionniers
avec votre sac et la première c'était le
premier spiritueux de la renaissance des
spiritueux au québec parce qu'on
s'entend qui avaient des spiritueux
avant la famille bronfman a fait des
milliards avec l'expliques-tu au québec
mais par une quarantaine d'années ça
disparu il ya vait cidre du vin de la
bière des alcools du de terroir très
spécifique tu es une liqueur de bleuets
sauvages que ces excellents métier c'est
très locale très artisanal qualitatifs
comme approche dans un magasin de
souvenirs aux all blacks
exactement nous allons laisser la grèce
sur les rails
photo na nours le fameux l'éthique de
tiflet mascaro à 50% des traits bicol la
voûte c'est là où le cas où le pire que
j'avais vu c'est une sculpture
amérindienne fait en chine
ouais bon ok ouais je sais qu'on a
envoyé l'artiste au moins c'est
quelqu'un qui m'avait dit un drapeau
acadien fait un choix en plus la cat iq
sont tellement fiers donc la canette
moi je me retrouve alors au à excuse
mais je veux revenir jean reno jean reno
a longtemps j'ai pris une grosse ouais
je n'ai renens
revenons à nos moutons pur vodka le
premier aujourd'hui 200 produits
peut-être je suis extrêmement fier d
être le premier quant à 40 ans
aujourd'hui j'avais 24 ans on est
extrêmement fier de ça le public les
textes revanche on est extrêmement
reconnaissant envers le public pour le
succès qu on convient que nos produits
et donc on a lancé ça ensuite on était
le deuxième jeune il y avait un gars à
pikine où je suis je vous disais
pourquoi parce que quand j'ai
l'inspirent vote que je voulais faire
aussi jean mais je n'avais pas l'argent
pour faire ni l'un ni l'autre
vous avez choisi celui qui est le plus
de potentiel de volume et c'était là la
vodka et donc j'ai commencé avec ça on a
dansé jean et les canettes la can est
encore les cocktails en canette existe
depuis quand même mon but mais nous on
est arrivé avec une renaissance encore
une fois une petite révolution dans un
marché où intérêt qu un produit 100%
naturel très bas très bas taux de ce que
très très peu de calories
aucun rajout dans nos produits avec une
image de marque complètement renouvelée
de ce qui existait avec une approche
très artistique ou si nous leur avenir
mais où c'est vraiment un ne va pas sans
l'autre et là on a vu l'explosion des
canettes et avec choco crème la crème si
beaux mecs bref on est très très très
innovateur dans une démarche proche très
très fier d'eux deuxièmement d'embellie
moment ben c'est sûr que moi la canette
ces camps
je veux boire un cocktail je vais pas
faire un cocktail je le bats c'est comme
quand j'ai faim je pourrais faire à
manger je veux marcher et d'autre le
cocktail la canette ça me dérangeait
d'abord avoir une option qui fêtait
selon mes standards de qualité donc je
voulais pas boire un demi litre du
cocktail de tes joues les gens un
cocktail musical mais je me répète trois
canettes mettez pas au one shot à 58 le
louvre ça devient un flat abandonné puis
un peu chaud ensuite je voulais pouvoir
l'utiliser peut-être ainsi autour de la
piscine on oublie une bouteille en vite
fait l'aluminium c'est parfait ensuite
un camping entre amis le qu'on avait le
temps de vivre le droit de vivre et donc
triste des moments que je voyais tous
comme étant un claque
voici à jen tonique testait un moment de
partage
choko crème bastin moment de gourmandise
j'ai eu l'idée en plein tournage de la
saison 8 des dragons d'amener qui est à
côté de moi de choco fav fréjus moi
j'aime beaucoup les crèmes sont très
bonnes d'ailleurs jamais dire que c'est
pas mon baby c'est bon on est bien mais
les braves alors on est 10 et est donc
aimons et j'avais bu choko belize le
soir l'avant de tournage puis le
lendemain on attend beaucoup un tournage
c'est quoi le pen je fais puni le
maquillage simple puis le shit chocolat
b chocolat belize dominique chocolats
favoris peuvent comme ces cargos ce
qu'est la loi
comme choco'croc en génie des faut qu'on
se parle après ok j'ai dit on fait un
temps pour tout le monde comprenne qu'on
prenne enfin berries au chocolat et
comme on may cry
ça va tellement marchiche comme au
maghred oui en fait c'était un moment de
gourmandise on voulait créer le lien
entre la fameuse fondue au chocolat de
choco fard ni le choco crème pitié avec
nous c'est toujours des moments pipi
puis avec roméo puis notre approche avec
l'art bâti c'est sûr que c'est aussi
faire briller les artistes puis le
talent d'ici et d'ailleurs aussi parce
qu'on fait des éditions dans nos autres
marchés à une artiste et puis bah ça
c'est le fun d'avoir un produit qui met
de l'avant s'est repris le produit mais
qui met de l'avant le talent de
quelqu'un d'autre aussi parce qu'il ya
un talent dans la bouteille ou dans la
canette mais un talent qui habille aussi
la canette ou la bouteille pss ça j'aime
beaucoup ça d'avoir une approche puis
pluri raisons qui mêle autant belle le
produit est bon mais la cause ou le look
est vraiment chic août
l'exemple tu donnes du de la crème la
crème chocolat tu mentes y est en toc
suffisait des produits pour combler un
désir que toi tu as vu puis je mets ça
avec avec quelque chose que je t'ai
entendu dire encore un prépare
aujourd'hui
ou est ce que tu dis que tu agis sait
beaucoup sur l'intuition plus que
n'importe quoi d'autre
absolument plus que de plans d'affaires
plus que 2 de planification de d'établir
l'effet mouton le bain je te dirais que
l'intuition ça va être ma première
démarche et ensuite je vais là je vais
la torture et andy mail a filtré à
travers un une étude de cas de
l'industrie je couds crème hockey l'idée
bonne parfait ensuite moi je m'imagine
toujours le consommateur final
choko crème quelque 40 saq quand ma tête
le jeu vous inviter le cac40 a effectué
de saint nicolas est ce que tu te fais
des clients oui oui je suis fière maman
vin blanc choco crème puis un nom c'est
oui ouais
laurent blanc et oui parce que moi ça
maintenant à visualiser la démarche les
vastes stationnements payants
expectations je cours je sais pas quoi
là les noms de compagnies saq
saint-nicolas sélection j'adore 7,7 saq
là tu arrives là bas tu vas dans la
division l'arrangé crème liqueur tu vois
le look choco crème avec très rapidement
tu comprends l'association de chocolats
favoris
tu salive et comme on accorde c'est un
cadeau que je me donne une courbe à un
moment gourmand que je me donne
c'est comme ça que je me suis dit oui
soya à ces deux mamans vin blanc mais
c'est l'objectif s'il n'a qu ils font la
pub avec lebron james lebron james
n'achète pas ses produits sous l'effet
de tout le monde qui n'est pas libre aux
jo il va j'ai d'abord hésité entre nous
on part avec une personne après il ya
tellement de clients différentes et est
donc après laon l'analyse on regarde
s'il ya une demande sur le marché
quand je dis si on demande c'est pas
nécessairement la tendance si c'est en
croissance ou en baisse j'aime beaucoup
constant baissent d'ailleurs parce que
j'aime renversé dans ce pilote en edge
mais c'est plus sur le volume j'adore
l'homme escale c'est trop petit de faire
tous pour moureu 315 tout match où on
est on est plus guilleret pour faire des
micro benoît et donc puis après ben mon
équipe moins ils savent ils forment
challenge est plus que passer parce que
c'est comme ça c'est dans l'obstination
positive qu'on va trouver le meilleur
angle d'attaqué le bon prix le bon
wedding le bon à tout ce que vous voulez
et donc c'est comme ça que quand on
travaille mais c'est sûr que jamais j'ai
une idée en regardant un statistiques du
match l'ont alors le rhum brun one lancé
le rembrandt qui marche tu peux pas rien
qu'une bonne idée comme ça parce que
c'est quand même
je trouve c'est plus romantiques comme
approche qui font qu'un photographe
classe et sexy ton idée le t il faut
qu'ils aillent edge pour jean le fichier
excel me dis que f 18 ça serait une
bonne idée
depuis c'est trop facile aussi comme ça
que tu passes à côté de ton affaire
parce que le tibet fait un produit pour
répondre à une demande
mais le vrai succès se créer un produit
pour créer une demande et le tue le tue
le marché de 7 est seul maître compris
mais on sait s'il voulait répondre à une
demande pas fait c'est quoi l'auto la
plus vendue si je sois là tu es d'accord
la soie la golf
rosa gangloff un petit hybride d2 le pij
a raison mais non le nom 130 pièces
électriques puis geiler de navettes
spatiales crée la demande
c'est fascinant la plupart des gens qui
nous écoutent j'imagine comes ton
histoire grosso modo c'est souvent un
resto à 23 24 24 aux échecs total qui
ensuite dieye ça va beaucoup de votre
came au resto je veux pas de votre
culture un pic pendant quatre ans
développe ce en travaillant temps plein
de soir de nuit à l'hôpital à la ville
blanche et il le jeu résume drama match
et qu'il raconte x ou y changent pas
mais moi questions ci est ce clip après
ce bon il faut que les produits dits
prêts t'approches à exécuter à écrire on
va aux [ __ ] vente ce nom ça marche pas
de même c'est pas que ça arrive et puis
non fait qu'on vendra pas ton produit tu
peux pas fok pileux un peu par chance et
par magie presse que tout cas tu
t'inscris un concours d'un jour suivant
puis une semaine plus tard tout ce qui
est gagné le prix de la meilleure vodka
au monde c'est l'histoire est incroyable
mais ma question ci dessus
méthon l'entrepreneur qui dit ça fait
quatre ans que je travaille sur ma
business je peux encore une scène tu
travailles être en pleine nuit qui put
excuse
en fait ce concept plutôt recommandé ton
histoire comme exemple non parce que je
suis extrêmement réaliste que j'ai gagné
la loterie d'une combinaison de facteurs
une pierre lachance définitivement la
chance très souvent le meilleur ami du
travail a personne tu aies jamais dit
les personnes valides pendant ces six
mois je pensais mais la chance bref j'ai
gagné un tri top beaucoup plus de chance
de partir de pas réussir que de réussir
ça c'est clair net et précis passé mais
tant que tu avais gagné mais quatrième
ayant vendu au monde méthodes quatrième
étage
points vélo une auto me rentrer dedans
je n'avais pas rencontré car carreaux
qui nous fait vivre toute l'année de mes
parents je serais né au pakistan il ya
tellement de facteurs que toi peut-être
une petite chance de réussir
c'est ça qui rend que c'est vraiment
difficile d'atteindre un objectif ou
d'atteindre la réussite tout dépendant
de sa définition de la russie cependant
pied en plus l'entrepreneur est une
science humaine et conscience peut être
à notre place comme est un philosophe t
c'est pas toujours aussi ce com ou
soirées de danse et à la comptabilité
c'est une des divisions importantes de
l'entrepreneuriat ou un univers et puis
ça ça fait deux on est d'accord mais tu
es comment payer un employé quand a pas
d'argent pas payer n'est pas olivier ben
je sais pas je l'inventé canettes et il
ya ça mais de l'autre côté aussi
moi je suis très réaliste danse dans le
fait que tu as quand même des facteurs
qui vont te donner des chances de
peut-être avoir une chance si tu veux
jouer pour canadienne ne s'est pas
patiné si tu patines bien une micro
chances de l'eau sans que celui de
patines battu mais plus de chances de
tomber
seaton certains parce que je sais que
dans le sport professionnel pas bêtes
sont un certain volume je fais 6 pieds 3
fait très attention à toi tu es très
athlétique du jour qui est depuis très
jeune ton père tu as donné ta mère tu as
donné cette passion là tu as la chance
d'avoir un sous-sol du temps passe d'un
fan finie amis 1-1 est dans le sous sol
tu peux pratiquer tout le temps des
parents peuvent inscrire des équipes
fortune obligé d'être riche en gaz est
une bulle ça coûte une fortune savait
que ce serait très sain tous ces
facteurs là ça coûte cher en crue du
hockey wayne gretzky faire l'écho nation
du ski pour une famille de trois enfants
bissau le jeu s'est acheté les trucs ya
le second vin qui est super intéressant
qui va tenir un stand entrepreneuriale
on peut reparler un taux mais mais mais
bref c'est fait mais il ya des facteurs
comme ça de la vie puis à des facteurs
aussi perso que tu peux contrôler est ce
que tu es prêt à accepter de laver les
planchers
on sait pas combien d'années pour
atteindre son objectif
maintenant oui il y en a un il y en a un
nom il abandonne y en a 2 ans il
abandonne
il y en a après deux ans ils ont un
enfant enfin j'ai pas le choix il faut
qu'il faut faire vivre
pour l'heure j'ai une responsabilité je
fais c'est tellement tellement compliqué
cependant disque que tu peux contrôler
est obligé d'avoir des surprises
la curiosité la préparation ton sérieux
dans sa démarche
ta recherche la discussion avec un
mentor il ya des organismes publics
municipaux provinciaux gouvernementaux
adopté le mouvement que j'ai lancé ce
sont pour les entrepreneurs fauque tâche
il faut que tu as cherché tout ce qui
existe deux gratuits il faut peut-être
99% vont va pas servir mais tu vas
l'avoir tchèque s'est fait ça c'est de
donner une chance
mais encore une fois tu peux absolument
tout foirer en ayant tout ce que j'ai à
dire
un exemple qu'il ya pas foirer parce que
c'est inventé mais le garçon de patrick
roy qui était un gardien de but qui
était quand même il s'était rendu quand
même avec junior majeur de harkis du
québec pour les remparts le thé à deux
doigts de la ligue nationale des broches
l'un s'est pas rendu son passé le
michael jordan de gardien de but
ils doivent une patte mort dans sa
chambre et avec les moyens de la réalité
il a vécu toute sa vie là-dedans
après je le connais pas le goy je crois
que tu attends tu te trompe pas dans les
rangs pas pour rien puis il ya pas fini
c'est la vie j'ai très difficile
d'atteindre fils ou une fille d'une
légende même les grosses et petites
sauces et à peut-être joué contre lui
parce que tu te compare toujours le
connaissent le connaissant bien longue
et moi ça m'a sauté beaucoup aux yeux
parce que t'es battu de sopi
je trouve ça triste plus qu'autre chose
je sais pas ce que c'était parce qu'ils
voulaient faire c'est ça tu vois mais
quand tu veux pas faire quelque chose tu
te rends ce niveau là il y avait et donc
peut-être se voit à quel point tu peux
tout avoir pas réussir tu peux rien à
voir réussir mais la feinte et histoire
le sait qu'il est peut-être en guinée
pour russie la première entreprise selon
lui obligé qui ces conflits ont fait 381
de grippe maintenant ici ça ça
fonctionne dit examen fonctionne
vraiment bien même [ __ ] vagabonder des
plaines lui un escalier en vendent
encore j'avais voulu dire encore se
promener partout il ya encore ça va
mieux mais tu vois tes fesses comme quoi
un échec témoin j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
plus d'échecs de succès mais je te
dirais que c'est c'est vraiment grâce
aux échecs je connais je crée
effectivement donné aussi il faut que tu
acceptes les échecs faut pas que si
teulet se définir par sa mini par le
succès l'air est-ce que tu qualifierait
mais tente ta carrière deux doigts de
basket que manager
pendant vingt ans ça a été un échec et
puis quand j'ai découvert mais
maintenant je me vibre j'ai arrêté d'en
à 21,22 je découvre peut-être à 35 que
c'était l'éthique de travail existe elle
aurait menti
j'avais pas parce que j'avais du talent
c'est un piège notamment effectué le
meilleur mais sans avoir rien fait tous
les hommes alors
non non non non un échec c'est pas
atteindre l'objectif c'est été donnée
mais des fois c'est comme mon resto
c'est vraiment un échec si le c'est le
plus beau cadeau de la vie fait qu un
échec it's à la presse qu est-ce que
c'est vraiment un échec mais c'est sa
vertu duquel t'apprendrai rien réagit
tout les toutes mes copines que j'ai eue
avant carreau certains marchent en amour
j'ai aimé pour certaines est ce un échec
qui fait en sorte que j'ai rencontrés
qu'à rochefort les saints que goethe
avec la seconde je les ai vus j'ai un
mari c'est tant mieux
c'est un bel échec - quand même temps
l'échec est considérée négatif quand ça
devrait pas ce que parce que l'échec qui
s'éteint extrême puis le succès sa note
extrait servi à ce qu'on parle de ce
qu'on disait tantôt on est toujours dans
l'extrême soit à l'échec soit sans
succès mais c'est pas parce que tu fais
pas 60 millions de revenus pain succès
puisse pas parce que ça n'a pas
fonctionné ce que tu as fait que c'est
un échec
moi je me répète mais ce qui est je leur
ai peut-être ma vie puis le monde ils
vont quand même dans l'extrême alors je
le répète moi ce que mon obsession
quotidienne
c'est dans mon chemin vers mon objectif
si j'ai une idée de lancer sur vos
crèmes je veux que ce soit un succès je
définis le succès on s'est mis nombre de
questions on a regardé tel le marché est
on est on sait défini sur 12 mois c'est
quoi un succès commercial si si les us s
il al ahly la barque rythme est
irréaliste toute étonnée chez qui l'on
doit faut bien et c'est ça qu'il faut
aller étape par étape et donc moi j'ai
choco crème dans ma tête je sais que je
veux vendre ex nombre de caisses dans la
première année mais tu sais que c'est
ici un que ça se décide
je peux enfin puisse pas au début c'est
dans ton chemin je comprends pas que le
monde oublie
que tu gagnes pas un marathon quand tu
cours au marathon tu gagnes les 700
heures de pratique que tu fais tu dis ça
mais je crois que c'est parce que c'est
la fast food ce samedi où il faut que ça
soit vite se soit fait feu tous connus
vite il faut que tu 400000 falloir vite
mais tout ce qui se bâtissent sur un
vide retombe dans le vide
quand du bâti quelque chose de solide
dont succès et perrin ça c'est important
c'est donc parce que j'avais une
discussion justement sur ça parce qu on
m'approche beaucoup pour parler de ce qu
on appelle ça me fait toujours rire la
nouvelle tendance de l' influence c'est
vieux comme le monde d'influenceurs l'on
veut se le dise maurice richard faisait
de la pub pour la bière très sous-payés
vers certains petits nouveaux mais la
pratique s'appelle le médium ou avec ces
nouveaux d'avoir une influence non mais
c'est plus nouveau mais d'avoir une
influence sur techtoc ou sur les
institutions mais c'est une c'est pas
nouveau pas tout pitié je dis toujours
c'est moi j'ai toujours une relation
complexe avec ce qu'on définisse comme
un influenceur ou une inférieure
pourquoi parce que je trouve ça dommage
que la majorité d'entre eux ou elles ne
comprennent pas qu'il faut être
propriétaire de son succès pas locataire
vous vous lancez un truc à vous vous
êtes influenceurs lausanne ont subi
pareil je suis aussi à certaines
manières et le mouv pop non plus le
marketing la définition du marketing
c'est de créer une action pour
influencer une personne influence et
rien ne nous volent mais et mettez vous
bâtissez quelque chose de se lancer dans
une aventure là là vous vous cherchez à
être propriétaire de votre influence
mais quelqu'un qui ne fait qu'une pub
après une plume sponsorisés ça peut être
une personne très agréable dans la vie
mais moi ce qui m'enrage moi je suis un
perfectionniste d'un entrepreneur pas l
entendre
elle lui passe à côté de quelque chose
même tu peux la chance aujourd'hui
d'avoir une influence
profites-en fait pas juste une pub on ne
paye à poursuivre un mois puis après je
cherche une autre
c'est ça c'est parce que souvent on
mélange les mots sur l' influence on
fait des ententes avec des influenceurs
à longueur de journée mais parce que une
influence c'est une campagne
publicitaire comme le faisait depuis
qu'il est né moi je crois pas en même
temps peut-être faut pas dire secret
mais il faut être propriétaire de son
succès sinon c'est la cata la vie clame
minutes tout est plus la fille qui dans
une sorte hector un autre prénom notre
300 millions d'autres c'est fait que ça
je trouve que c'est important mais sur
le fond beaucoup plus mais voit son nez
avec le business dans le sang la moto
unis et ils n'ont pas peur de faire de
l'argent ce pas tabou faire de l'argent
puis ils ont pas peur de l'échec
ça c'est beaucoup de points qui fait en
sorte que tu fonces si tu sais bien je
vais m'acheter une page extrêmement
volontaire et tu vas voir un fournisseur
et empoche un wet charge trônant
kressmann dirige jusqu'en juin que mon
argent je sais c'est une porsche
ben ouais moi j'ai des choses et puis
j'en ai pas de porsche le j'ai pas du
tout j'avais une auto pendant un an
puisque je faisais cela démarré pour
cadet marc angers le droit d'aller
quelque part
ouais bien sûr qu'on est obligé d'avoir
un camion là parce que on a trois
enfants
je suis spécialement fameux fesf est là
chez nous des mini le mal à l'aise et ça
c'est des gros modèles bopb tout moi
tout ça pour dire que non c'est sorti je
trouve que je suis très tôt puis je
regarde ça c'est pire moi j'aimerais que
j'ai le défaut de vouloir que les autres
atteignent chercher puis j'ai rien à
gagner
du point de vue si à trois millions de
personnes qui écoutent votre truc que
vous gagnez - non non il jette legault
le moins douter de votre saison a rendu
un million de followers maintenant mais
vous comprenez mais ce parce que j'aime
savoir les autres il se tait cette femme
devant les autres pour moi que je
je suis impliqué dans mille et un trucs
pour aider franchement c'est cool c'est
un buzz réussir tc où habitait ça
n'enlève rien au final td fois cette
espèce de jalousie passe et la jalousie
outils cet espèce de feeling c'est comme
si l'autre us à côté de toi de toi cette
année de rien at-on succès août c'est la
baston se définit on se définit par part
ça encore une fois et non par la
démarche
c'est peut-être ça peut-être que le
monde jalouse de certains influenceurs
où la démarche pour certains je connais
pas exactement n'a pas toujours été la
plus complexe que d'autres si on va se
le dire être être sélectionné dans une
émission comme occupation double du jour
au lendemain tu as aimé personne qui te
suit les frères géant 30
alors c'est sûr que c'est pas j'ai dû
travailler huit ans a ramassé dans une
écurie avec le foin sahel pour avoir une
chance d'avoir une photo qui a bien
marché mais après beaucoup de chance sa
chance ou des stratégies aussi
moi je serais je suis un gars de 20 20
ans aujourd'hui 21 22 clair que je
m'inscris ce truc-là essaie de te faire
de cadeaux avant d'y aller l'appui
pour maximiser les chances d'être
sélectionné puis baincthun tonnes
clientèle t'en sors avec le public de
l'examen précis statut directement le
cip à la charge des brûlés aussi exact
je pense que le monde s'en rend compte
très rapidement qu'ils sont sans pitié
c'est oui on like it's done les
problèmes suite mme way
mais c'est une belle c'est une belle
étude sociologique dans vingt ans de
voir comment cette nouvelle affluence
sur les réseaux sociaux va va évoluer
qui va sur ses petits comme gagnant puis
perdre en langue email les ghats larges
pour être les premiers à jouer le
maintien
plus plus séquencée nouveau succès est
arrivé le savez pas nécessairement
comment ça existait peau qui ont créé
cette jobs le ceo qui était passée après
ça c'est plus quelque chose semble
facile puis une mine d'or le ton monte
et non cela n'a pas manipulé y en a
beaucoup qui mais comme tous les
extrêmes c'est ça valait 1 extrême après
sa vague brut puis va rester ce qu'ils
méritent ou qui ont quelque chose à dire
d'être l'hôte
mais c'était quand même vraiment tant
qu'entrepreneur puis de thé qu'on
sélectionne nous avec qui on veut
approcher pour représenter notre marque
et qu on approche quelqu'un le sait on
ne donne mon bébé dans un par un
c'est une grosse responsabilité de de
notre part de faire confiance à une
personne qu'on connaît pas c'est une
question que je me posais parce que nous
on
on avait une discussion avec une agence
qui s'occupait d'influenceurs que eux
sont retrouvés en plus dans le pétrin
avec le fait que certains de leurs
influences heures sont fait prendre dans
des scandales des affaires puis ça dans
le fond c'est que tseng thon tu fais tes
une compagnie t'annonce pour le canadien
de montréal teuton logo sur la page
tu peux pas être éclaboussé par ces
choses là quand tu choisi de travailler
avec une personne c'est quand même de
chez l'autre parce que tu sais pas
qu'est ce qui peut se passer comme ça ta
marque est associée cette personne là on
l'a vu dans d'actualité avec mac pierre
morin toutes les marques et à bonningues
marque était elle a lavé reebok bio et
sa propre compagnie d'un vêtement de
maillots de bain noir avec des
fournisseurs petit tu t'attaches à une
personne peut l'être humain est un
parfait mais ça c'est quand même
taccetti de vouloir comme tu disais de
choisir donné ton bébé à quelqu'un mais
que cette personne l'oeil et au final
une humanité quand éric salvail
ouais je suis bien placé pour parler moi
j'avais une copine juste société avec
lui les recettes pompette et du jour au
lendemain ça a été le jeu ça c'était le
plus vendu de l'histoire l'on s'entend
là un succès dans une société juste cinq
dix mille copies
le premier mois qu'on avait lancé cette
tempête on a vendu pas loin de cent
mille copies world quoi on l'a lancé en
novembre et a fini plus vendu de l'année
l'année d'apprendre la danse en france
parce qu'elle s'est trompée texte en
france ont lancé aussi une date
pouilleuse on a fini jean 5e jeu le plus
vendu 80 millions d'habitants
ça a été un méga succès la veille qu'on
lançait la la suite l'auteur cette
compet deux phares et et on a encore je
suis content centaines de milliers sont
entreposés quelques poèmes fête du bois
ça c'est une superbe leçon que c'est
pour moi moi je ne connaissais pas ce
cas là ouais mais je connaissais comme
un homme comme céline dion puis par pur
hasard un moment donné quelqu'un
m'appelle à la première ou deuxième
émission de recettes pompette quand il
avait lancé sa piste est pur vodka qui
prenait le marketing comment on a fait
une entente perdit nom de cause par sa
belle pub déjà en prend le labo a tort
quand même temps je suis même pas sûre
et dit oui si nous avons approché parce
que je suis pas pour le je suis
extrêmement réaliste dans ma situation
moi je te produis moi je croise une
drogue dans l'association je peux gagner
ce match au japon vérifier prendre c'est
pas un moment là tu n as qu est que je
rentre je t'aime maman d'un côté notre
premier jeu peu comme seule façon je me
lève à 5 heures du matin de la semaine
j'ai troqué mai puis de toute manière
j'ai dépassé cette étape long le tous
fait mais pour moi pilar
ça passe plus on voit vraiment qu'il ya
un engouement un engouement alors moi
j'ai une idée comme tout le temps puis
l'idée ben moi c'est le mans qui me
l'ont donné parce que le monde dans la
rue bambins je t'aime beaucoup moins
connus languit mais dans le temps mais
ils m'ont me reconnaissais puis il s'est
fait station pour les phases est mon
petit allemande ou parce qu'on on joue
avec votre mode qu'à auch adoré cette
tempête jeu comme un jour recettes donc
en ce jour supposément bien tu essaies
de faire manger petit soultz comme c'est
sur le juteux juge pas demandés a
précisé cette personne qui me disent hk
l'icwa fox il ya quoi faire axa puis
c'est un endroit parce que je déteste
les jeux de société jeux de société
plus maintenant à cause des enfants mais
quand j'ai dit à carreaux j'ai une idée
enfin juste c'était un homme coincé par
un cap c'est juste citer qu'eux c'est
aujourd'hui comme je préférais de
torture etc sont torturés qualifie la
belle famille jouer carmen sandiego
c'est là je vais aller nettoyer je
pourrais le fond de ruelles et et est
donc je réussi à rentrer en contact avec
sa productrice
bref et je peux te l'idée c'est un
endroit parce que je vais rencontrer
deux fois la première fois pour
expliquer le concept puis la branche
chose qui me disait j'aime pas les jeux
de société je dis moi non plus histoire
de foot et la deuxième fois quand il
annonça son choc était sale
on dirait qu'on a fait comme ça en
matière de ramassage pour la photo est
donc bon je voyais que c'était une
quelqu'un d'extrêmement mais je veux
mais je n'ai pas dans l'industrie la
nuit fait je soupçonnais pas du tout
comme quoi tu peux tout perdre mais pour
tous revenir à une personne
oui la personne c'est dangereux parce
que maintenant l'influencent c'est une
entreprise c'est une personne et c'est
une connerie ou l'apparence d'une
connerie tu es mort pour ça que quand tu
es propriétaire
il faut que se battre contre
qu'intelligent à main
il faut que tu t'es fait au maximum de
dépersonnaliser que tu fasse plus partie
de tak de ben oui parce qu'à lisez mon 6
po vivable puis dieu sait que j'ai rien
à me reprocher mais toujours nicolas
nicolas nicolas
avantage une équipe de feu j'ai des
produits de feu j'étais fait qu'on
essaie de de jouets jeux et jouets sont
trop doucement puis sexy toi mais ton
site wat arrive quelque chose ou qui tu
fais une erreur purement de jugement
mais le service d'éclaboussures et où la
compagnie est en jeu sauf que sauf que
mettons dans ta situation à toile ça
risque de continuer à exister
l'eau de toilette oui mais dans nos
autres jeux au japon
roméo super populaire et vous continuez
à petits pas plein mais peut-être
regarde les cas juste pourri le roseau
son entreprise
non je ne signerai 9 claque salve est
mort marie pierre qui avait des projets
que je soupçonne commence à faire un bon
revenu à nos morts se nomme à double
tranchant ton influence plus rapidement
à venir plus rapidement à peu
disparaître maintenant
encore une fois on vit dans le fast-food
society tout doit être même la cour de
justice
elle est immédiate c'est que la foule
je veux qu'on parle avant 2 avant de
terminer de l'activité physique puis de
commencer parce que nous on est on est
d'aider des athlètes encore aujourd'hui
on est des anciennes en jeûnant juge qu'
à l'université l'université ne serait
jamais mérité pas 12 mais ouais fait que
fait moi mettons dans les dernières
années parce que je suis plus un
entrepreneuriat maintenant laisser les
moments où est ce que je suis vraiment
le mieux c'est lé moment ce que je
m'entraîne le plus je peux comprendre
que ça n'at-on tia on avait une énorme
journée pour le studio lethier vraiment
une journée l'oder mur à mur puis en
arrivant à l'appartement
je te saturé il fallu qu'on a des
cendriers fait que j'allais m'entraîner
on est allés ensemble puis pendant que
tu t'entraînes dieu comme un genre de
clarté d'esprit clarté d'esprit qui
revient hanter puis trop c'est quelque
chose que premièrement en mettant une
athlète qui avait déjà le sport c'était
pas c'était pas ovni pour toi le 10 puis
que comment est ce que tu balances sont
maintenant puisque tu as toujours
balancé puis sinon c'est quand remarquer
il fallait que ce facile j'avais détesté
ma réponse là mais pendant dix ans j'ai
arrêté toute activité pour mille une pop
aux bonnes raisons que je vais vous
donner réponse est nette entre l'art et
des planches j'étais stressé par dessus
la tête de rentrer dans ta bulle
et puis tu travailles tu travailles tu
travailles toute des raisonnements
désespérément cette année qu'en cas
roman foutu dehors du travail
j'ai comme eu un réveil où j'étais je
trouvais mes enfants lourd dans mes bras
ouais je peux 87 le plat est pris du
poids je t'ai pas focus jusqu'à 1 faut
que je fasse un changement drastique
je vivais plus de 20 mais tout le monde
a vu plus de mails c'est pourtant que
j'exagère paul annacone mais j'ai
toujours énormément parti vert la
semaine
à 16h18 en 1h com - ni un ni l'autre et
et j'ai eu 40 ans en octobre fait qu'en
juillet je me suis témoin
je vais pas mourir je me suis dit le
terrain je veux pas mourir 45 d'un
problème de chez pas quelle connerie
parce que j'ai tellement stressée roule
à 240 km à petit je peux pas faire ça à
ma famille à moi premièrement pour de
vrai j'ai pensé à ma famille avant mais
il faut le faire pour soi
mettez moi surtout mes enfants je peux
pas leur faire ça je les aime tellement
et et donc je me suis donné un défi un
moment puis je les radis public parce
que juste moi j'ai une parole et quand
je dis quelque chose je le fais vous
allez rire parce que aux dragons dans
une des épisodes c'est pour quand est ce
qu'on va passer une entrepreneur qui est
venu pitch et des habits de pole dancing
qui est un sport en europe les états
unis ici-bas fait référence aux
danseuses ceni l'eau mais c'est devenu
un sport
et puis bon je voudrais pas la suite
mais regardez ça parce que vous êtes
extrêmement surprise du dragon de devoir
pourtant un poteau tout ça pour dire que
c'est quand je dis quelque chose je fais
est là alors je suis très proche de
l'entreprenant daniel des newquay
derrière car du plana que tu sur ton
pote et j'adore cette personne là
j'avais rencontré dans un tournage
dragon j'aimerais te dragon invité
l'année dernière et je la paie jeudi il
faut il faut que je m'entraîne jamais
été un gars de jim plus rien contre
legend mais je faisais du vote ce qu'a
fait jouer au basket bouthinon soir que
moi j'adore puis l'hiver j'avais j'ai
pas adopté de sports d'hiver encore
quand j'étais jeune joueur orc et comme
tout le monde je m'étais après je suis
comme perdu le fil et je suis donné un
défi de m'entraîner à partir de début
septembre 40 fois pour mes 40 ans défie
40 40
avec un entraîneur de 4 planeur j'avais
besoin de quelqu'un qui ment gueule
gothique qui m'oblige qui me pousse que
j'avais misé sur une période deux
communautés à peu près c'était 3 4 fois
semaine c'est quand même intense pour
dix ans rien fait bon mais je peux pas
le problème et touring
ouais
et donc je faisais aussi tous les
mercredis en live j'ai pris des heures
que je peux pas me dire c'est trop tôt
c'est trop tôt c'était 3 à l'après midi
ça me semble déranger parce que c'est no
ma journée de travail tellement mais il
fallait que je suis obligé de le faire
mais des comptes à rendre
je vais des contrats rang de la north et
quand ça c'est un des plages pour un
entrepreneur croire que ce tatouage
business oui c'est à toi business
metacom des comptes à rendre et je les
fait gelé très bien fait perdu depuis je
n'ai pas fait pas peur du poil
nécessairement je les fais tu pour
reprendre père du genre 20 livres font
du lhotse là j'ai repris un pelage et
plupart encore là depuis à février là
parce que j'ai deux trois douches il en
tout cas bref je vais recommencer les
excuses des excuses c'est toujours des
excuses à présenter des infos que je
retombe dans ma petite dame en routine
et ça a été le jour et la nuit pour le
monde autour de mathieu qu'est ce qui se
passe comme tout changer quelque chose
j'étais complètement différent beaucoup
plus concentrés donc plus productifs
beaucoup plus patient je quelqu'un
patients la mettrais patienter comme moi
jouer le parterre des fois je sais plus
quoi faire avec les enfants tout comme
tout parent joue mal mais là je savais
plus quoi faire vraiment longtemps je
décorais exclu juste comme un mail à
meilleur nick pour moi mais qui me
rendait meilleurs pour tous non ça c'est
fou comment tu as touché quelque chose
de si tu es un bon un bon quoi que ce
soit ça passe par tafer santé physique
et mentale absolument obligatoirement
obligatoirement je le vois je suis moins
concentrées là depuis de mottet je le
vois que j'ai toute ma démarche pour me
relancer dans maps attentes mais je le
vois assez foule fait qu effectivement
mettez ça revient à ce qu'on disait de
d'atteindre un succès ou un point une
strate là où il ya peu de monde
ben toi tu es comme une formule que la
forme une autre voie pour mettre des
pneus quatre saisons nature exacte des
pneus sur mesure
pas durer lui lire un plomb ou même je
sais pas quoi comme ils appellent ça
maintenant les trucs extra pas quoi tu
vas mettre développe un et sans juste
pour ces machines là c'est des
ingénieurs et des docteurs change des
tenues toutes plus précis que s'il ya le
moindre truc peut faire en sorte que tu
gagnes une course rupture en allemand
même affaire pour une personne quand tu
vas à atteindre le quand tu te fasses
que les autres arrivent pas à faro où
c'est difficile à atteindre
j'ai un ami qui a fait d'elle qu'à gravi
l'everest s'est entraîné un an le salut
devant nous avec un grain de l'autre
parce que tout des prix sur assiette une
telle est la quitte le quai match je le
comprends et donc moi je suis très
content de ça par exemple parce que ça
rend l'atteinte d'objectifs difficile
puis trouve que ça doit être difficile
pour pas que tout n'importe quoi puis
pour que ceux qui réussissent en quelque
sorte le mérite par le travail par le
sacrifice par l'importance qu'ils ont
mis à leur préparation puis pas juste
aux malgré de superbes en course je
gagnerai 100 m aux jeux olympiques ça
serait tellement plate faut rêver moi ça
me fait rêver de voir ça moi quelqu'un
qui captait les plus grands shows mais
j'ai je les regarde pas comme disons un
phénomène michael jordan
non moi quand je vois michael jordan je
pense à certains moments de sa carrière
où il ya un moment particulier c'était
la finale à salt lake city leur leurs
ennemis jurés
il y à une intoxication alimentaire
il ya perdu gens qui nous livre dans la
nuit à vomir le médecin de l'équipe a
dit au propriétaire il ne peut pas jouer
c'est dangereux pour sa vie
c'est quand même parce que tu sais quand
tu fais pas tu perds beaucoup indiv à
déshydrater il va tomber un choc mais
que je ne dois rien ça va y arriver même
pas marcher du match où on ajoute il
savait c'était quoi le symbole que
michael jordan joue pas on y comprenez
il était plus grand que lui chez
l'ennemi
ça donne sud et alto mais quand tu veux
non jeu contre les boss des com - mais
quand je n'étais pas là où on peut
prendre et trois corners soir et t on
s'entend
mais pour ses coéquipiers pour toutes il
voulait pas abandonner le propriétaire
de reprendre décision le propriétaire il
disait moi je peux pas prendre le risque
d'une vie humaine
mais quand tu joues pas il était
tellement story ils y apprennent avocat
puis il ya écrit une lettre de décharge
pour les assurances de la ligue de
l'autre russe il signala 6 passe quoi
que ce soit 100% de ma faute personne ne
payait atteint maniaque l'eau par
exemple à suivre mais moi je trouve ça
quand même
et pendant le match on le voyait témoin
mills a sûrement les photos de sites de
ce match le cdh a couvert de sueur il y
avait des intraveineuses achète de l'eau
saline voyance grippé peine
d'exceptionnel sifflets courait vers lui
pour le prendre parce qu'il pouvait pas
supporter il a fait 47 points m c'était
une marche pendant longtemps on pensait
que c'était le match whisky avril la
grippe mais que finalement mis
dernièrement on a appris que c'était
parce qu'il y avait des gueux qui ont
amené une pizza jampy légaux comme fait
de quoi tout pour que ces les guides
sont les baptistes et pour donner une
excuse pour le rendre malade doyon à mon
pilotage
le flou game mais fait que j'allais à la
game de grippe mais finalement si on
appris je passe devant de la scène
le documentaire devrait peut-être moi je
l'avais lu dans un des meilleurs livres
monde eleven ring de ferraille
mais d'un autre oeil métier des
histoires comme ça moi moi ça me fait
triper ça me fait triper des personnes
qui m la personne de côté pour une cause
une raison un objectif commun je n'étais
pas et puis ils font ultimes sacrifices
pour réussir c'est comme aujourd'hui où
on veut toujours tout vite l'éloge de la
lenteur l'éloge de prendre son temps de
bien le faire moi je sais très important
pour moi
je trouve qu'on compare ça mais ce
qu'ils font ont beaucoup plus de chances
de réussir sans casque est c'est parti
sur quelque chose de vrai et il le défi
ultime on dirait c'est de réussir sa vie
sport d'entrepreneuriat d'emprunt porte
puis aussi de réussir sa vie personnelle
parce que la vie professionnelle c'est
et russes et à ce niveau le si ça
demande tellement dedication des
sacrifices parce que si ces sites
mondiaux d'avoir l'équipe de russie
aussi sa vie professionnelle parce qu'en
bout de ligne d'air ont vu juste une
fois les humains autour de nous qui
gravite ceci quelqu'un qui nous aime
qu'on aime tpiy c'est surtout du fait
que souvent entre le génie et la
personne normale dont il ya une extrême
et alors comme un coach de rennes
tu voyais dans leur stand et j'aimerais
est un psychiatre ou un psychologue
spécialisé polymers le pot limit cinq
ans que des personnes comme il aime
masque t il ya deux ou trois bébés tout
comme tout le monde
steve jobs il ya une trop vite une red
bull steve jobs
les athlètes de petit michael schubert
dans un thé frôlé la mort au quotidien
c'est pas normal non il faisait voulu
comme fait que toute une
tout un point très intéressant comme moi
ça me passionne seulement l'être humain
passionne parce que on fait de grandes
choses du téléphone
moi franchement la regarde j'ai
cependant à connaître mais j'aime ce est
justement etc on parle de sport dip
tantôt le même ceux pour assister à la
great neck ses yeux rien mode pour le
reste de ma vie je vais me rappeler si
je me rappelle de kindu en septembre
mettant je me rappelle mais je me
rappelle je sois moins marqué que huit
médailles d'or aux jeux c'est la
dernière fraction de seconde
le sud-coréen qui a failli le battre
c'est sa dernière non non non c'était
pas le score
les français n'ont laissé tester le gars
c'était le gueut le serbe au 100
papillon nous inquiète pas le relais
mais c'est exactement ce que je voulais
je voulais assister à l'histoire si je
voulais pour dire avait fait regarder
les huit courses ou est-ce que gagné ses
huit médailles d'or écoute c'est
vraiment rire parce que c'est exactement
moi c'est des moments comme témoin les
moments que je me rappelle de ma ville
que vous allez rire mais c'est quand le
pape jean paul ii est mort l'élection de
nouveaux papiers à la fameuse sans
résumé blanche déjà j'ai dû attendre
trois jours dans l'atelier parce que je
voulais pas moins c'est ce mois ci mais
en même temps j'en ai rien à crisser
qu'il pape et ses traditions bien mais
je voulais voir sauter quand un incident
à l'histoire assister à l'histoire c'est
g profession j'ai fait sciences
politiques par défaut mais j'adorais
ceci dit c'est moi je te maniaque
d'histoire puis je me rappelle la
première guerre du golfe je suis trop
jeune j'avais 11 ans avec 191 c'est
quand saddam hussein a envahi le koweït
joker
c'était le début est celle du
livejournal pour vraiment le début mais
bref ça prend forme
comme je réalisais quelque chose s'est
dit ok je ne gagne une gaze et ses vrais
gens qui se tirent dessus le tcd moment
historique long septembre j'étais ma
première année d'université en sciences
politiques au nom arrive
j'écoutais ça je crois trois semaines de
suite et des moments comme ça que je
trouve moi c'est moi ça me fait c'est
une fois c'est sûr exact exact c'est
petit même si je m'en foutais comme là
quand la reine
je suis un homme l'a pas maintenant
j'imagine mais quand il va décéder
il va avoir une course c'est quoi c'est
quoi acheter un fait qd et c'est
impressionnant a juste vives ou voir des
personnes moi j'aime beaucoup le
cyclisme de route
j'ai eu la chance de voir plusieurs
étapes du tour de france puis à un
moment donné tu sais j'étais comme très
bien placé pour mille et une raisons là
je voyais les supplices devant moi ok
c'est quand je gagnais le tour de france
il ya peut-être 50 dans la ville de nice
part d'humanité qui ont gagné le jeu
comme auch est ces luttes
un mot sur des exploits qui sont aussi
été aussi impressionnant c'est la plus
débile au monde
puis tout le monde mais surtout de jeu
belge justement je m'assure tout c'est
quand même sur le meilleur débraillé
j'aime beaucoup
huawei ou des chercheurs ceux qui ont
découvert comme comme professeur
montagnier un prochain un professeur de
médecine en france qui a été un vraiment
le père et deux de la découverte du sida
c'était quand même ok man j'ai calé j'ai
découvert ça c'est big c + b que big ben
avant c'était une hécatombe
aujourd'hui avec tous les traitements
tout ils peuvent vraiment eu peu vu
toute ta vie excédés on peut comprendre
la maladie du sud ah non moi je mène à
tout ce monde là franchement moi ça
m'impressionne c'est intéressant si on
parlait juste avant le début du podcast
qui es tu nous parler des podcasts qui
est écoutée dictée vocale histoire de
politique de sciences je m'entraîne
jamais plaint des céréales killer piteux
pas nommer un podcast d'entrepreneuriat
ça me colle ont surpris parce que théo
on dirait qu'on est l'image de
l'entrepreneur qui fait juste lire des
livres d'art y écouter les livres audio
d'autres pas varié aux gens sur somme
puis c'est ce qui se sait que juge qui
drôles sont directs et complètement
l'inversé t'adresses à plein d'affaires
par le panaf avec têtu qui dévouent
quand même partie ton temps à autre
chose que l'entrepreneuriat oui parce
que moi je suis convaincu à la vie à la
mort qu'une une bonne connaissance
générale vont beaucoup plus qu'une
excellente connaissance d'un seul sujet
je peins experte en général et je
m'entoure d'experts et je veux tous
savent je préfère savoir 1% de son sujet
différent que 100 personnes un seul
sujet et je te le jure que un balado sur
gustave eiffel que j'aime beaucoup comme
comme ingénieur qui est derrière la tour
eiffel me donne des superbes idées on a
fait une méthode de gérer ou une image
de moi je dis souvent maintenant que
notre planète une tour eiffel avec ses
deux pieds la tour eiffel en quatre mais
ses deux pieds solidement ancrés au sol
une stature fier une tête sur les
épaules
mais une flexibilité parce que quand il
vante la tour eiffel et bouge de plus
d'1 5 m donc je trouve que c'est une
belle analogie ans vers
l'entrepreneuriat où il faut avoir les
deux pieds sur terre faut être fier de
toi faut pas voir pas si plus' fait pas
beau s'y fait soleil
s'il ya des guerres mondiales la tour
eiffel est restée la bière elle illumine
mais elle est extrêmement flexible la
tête
l'entrepreneur doit toujours regarder
partout effective des trucs comme ça mon
cheval et des références comme ça
puis je l'appelais quotidien et c'est
pour ça que je crois aussi que j'arrive
à me faire accepter quand même temps je
m'en voudrais de ne faire accepter kim
kong mais j'arrive à me faire accepter
autant par le bec québec inc ou c'est
juste que j'ai trois ans ce concert une
station d'investissement québec qui est
une banque gouvernementale levier
financier gouvernemental
puis de l'autre côté je fais des balados
avec vous avec le maire de laval avec
qui on parle dès hier on a parlé de manu
militari pitt et moi je me suis dis je
je crois tellement c'est tellement
important de culture générale une
culture générale c'est avoir un peu de
tout ça dans tout cela parce que tu peux
parler à tout le monde peut qu'y le clic
est extrait connexion pour parler de
natation pendant une heure
parce que je souhaitais ouvert d'esprit
de regarder un documentaire mené sur
fait de lire un petit article comme
sauvette vite puis d'être impressionné
aussi léger où les journalistes sont
extrêmement bons et raconter ce noël
tout un chacun infection c'est vraiment
passionnant
puis bref ouais moi en tout cas c'est
comme ça que je vis je suis extrêmement
bien comme ça oui problème c'est qu'à
tellement de sujets intéressants que sa
fille n'ait pu amener ne peux pas faut
accepter aussi doit être qu'un an et moi
c'est off
ouais c'est un beau problème on n'a même
pas parlé de mes passions j'ai des cours
d'allemand l'agriculture verticale ou la
grille tueur intérieur gais que ça soit
je sais que je sais pas toi mais qui est
un approche spécifique avec la bouffe ça
c'est l'eldorado extrême selon moins de
bâtir avec une énergie propre
les produits 100% locaux 100% biologique
sans même avoir besoin de faire
attention qu'ils le soient ils ils ne le
sont pas ce qu'ils sont cultivés dellal
la première fraction de seconde d'une
manière 100 % naturel moi ça me fait
triper j'ai une aventure
entrepreneuriale très certainement ça où
j'aimerais beaucoup plus que douteuse 0
mais une ferme une ferme un peu
expérientiel expliqué l'esmo expliqué
dans le sens où développer les
meilleures pratiques
je veux pas faire d'argent etc ce projet
là je veux au contraire investir pour
développer des meilleures pratiques
ensuite les pâturages et les données
c'est le cas des magazines je sais me
donner ton patron de wabho exactement
puis c'est pas toutes les fermes qui
peuvent investir en recherche et
développement sur comment faire en sorte
que lorsqu'on fait là
désolé mais tu sais ton l'élevage de
porc basque est une manière beaucoup
plus humaine beaucoup plus oui mais il
ya le post un exemple que je donne mais
ils sont déjà très avancées mais il ya
plein d'affaires que j'aimerais vraiment
et en même temps j'aimerais que les que
ce soit pour les écoles pour filles
nervosité parce que c'est pas normal
qu'un enfant de cet us 12 ans et jamais
vu un poulet de sa vie il pense qu'un
poulet c c'est dans une ambiance et ce à
la lumière de l'entrevue de dimanche
passé à tout le monde en parle avec je
ne sais plus où est le seul à gonesse en
faisant ça tu risques de te heurtes et à
certains lobbys qui vont sûrement
essayer de te mettre des bâtons dans les
roues pour changer les méthodes de
culture
oui absolument c'est pour ça que je
réussir au maximum chacun protège son
son territoire mais tu vois moi je le
vois toujours d'une approche
encore une fois il ya les deux extrêmes
on oublie le milieu c'est pourtant dans
le big mac ce qui est bon et au milieu
le pain ou lopin temps mais ça lève haut
la réalité aussi à travers albion beat
appelons le vit au muy chacun pense
chacun réfléchisse chacun est influencé
par son expérience puisqu'il connaît
fateh son chat job ils viennent une
maison payée à des enfants à nourrir
moi je comprends absolument cependant je
crois sincèrement qu'on peut trouver des
milieux qui répondent aux besoins pas ça
pour ça métier on n'est pas des
dictateurs si l' on peut tu comme laissé
sur la table qui pointe et je suis
convaincu je suis convaincu sans doute
temps de nous beaucoup de travail
beaucoup de beaucoup de il faut voir il
faut il faut que tes actions démontrent
que tu as raison rendre à un moment
donné c'est c'est ben beau dire il ya
700 ans
la terre on a taillé rona t.ron tourner
parce qu'ils étaient plate train bateau
va le prouver tout va prouver qu'un
horizon qui est qui
numérique et ont brûlé le monde qui dit
que la terre était ronde fait tout tout
tout ce fait mais malheureusement pas
brusquement
cependant le grand problème la pointure
de nanterre c'est que la planète est
déjà détruit on peut pas prendre le
temps qu'on parle des fois aussi de se
retrouver dans le milieu pour
l'activiste environnement environnement
environnementalistes qui sait à quel
point on y lit 23h59 pic on est dans la
merde il faut kg le sais pas si c'est
pas assez parce qu'il faudrait faire en
même temps ce détail dans les régions à
son combat aussi il dit que shell c'est
c'est le pire ennemi de l'humanité
non non il n'en est peut-être la raison
peut-être pas raison je sais pas mais tu
peux pas tu peux pas trouver une
solution positive avec des termes
négatifs peut pas dire t'es un connard
mais je t'aime il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on se regarde dans les yeux puis
qu'on trouve des solutions ensemble
toutes les grandes découvertes où les
grands projets peuvent projets ou les
grands programmes internationaux qui ont
été faits sont là la première
transplantation cardiaque c'était sept
pays qui sont mis ensemble pour
développer toute cette technologique
d'un point de vue médical ça changer le
monde cadets les vaccins c'est quand
même oui on était tous fâchés contre les
compagnies on s'est dit que c'est ça
leur donne la développer des vaccins
qu'on en est là c'est grâce à ces
compagnies là qu'on va s'en sortir au cc
sans qu'on voit sont sincères et
milliards de dollars de plaintes pays
qui ont donné ça pour faire accélérer la
recherche pour trouver une solution
ensemble coûte
est ce que c'est la meilleure des
solutions je ne sais pas mais c'est une
solution moins puissent commencer par
être qu'on en avait pas doté ses hommes
infectés je trouve que on est en hiver
ce python merci infiniment à la
conversation il est vraiment cool super
gentil merci d'être
l'invitation avant que le poker se
termine le 100 papillon aux olympiques
en 2008 semir l'adq avicii je voulais
pas laisser à la merci merci merci
d'abord écouté ses podcasts jusqu'à la
fin de ce pas que vous avez apprécié la
conversation ça prouve que vous êtes de
réelles fans de conversation et du
sans-fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez voir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe bien sûr peut tuer a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu on les
tourne donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pétrole mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs au monde paie turinois ce
que on parle d'homme nicole et moi de la
conversation convient d'abord parce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets qu'on voulait aborder ou
qu'on abordés pendant le podcast donc
allez sur notre page de turenne les
liens vers savoir dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fonte